yeah surprise
yeah we don't have we still don't have a
leg [ __ ] we still have an intro for
this
yeah i keep forgetting about it and then
it's just kind of like
so every time we go on i'm just always
kind of like
oh yeah it just seems so lame that's
like anti-climactic it is
yeah oh it's us again yeah
we were just here yes once again this is
another side track
and this is where jenny and i just
[ __ ] ramble for a couple of hours and
drink
so like every other show like every
other show the only difference is
that you guys kind of pick the topic
based upon
the comments in the comment section and
uh
for those of you who are not in the live
stream or watching this recorded you can
just sit back and have a drink
and listen to us [ __ ] bamboozle
everybody we're just gonna bamboozle
[ __ ]
and it'll probably like if you're if you
drink it'll probably make a lot more
sense
we're gonna bamboozle our way through
this show
because we don't want because we don't
have a topic these are fun though i like
doing these they're very fun
because it's just kind of like i can
just hang out with you guys i can just
drink if i forget what i was talking
about it doesn't really matter
i don't have to do any research ahead of
time you know these
shows are kind of remind me of dan
bill's quiet time where he just sits
there and tells the story
but they're not quite man those are so
great yeah yeah well he tries but then
he but then he starts cracking him
stretches
which also makes because he tries to do
like the the lowdown like asmr voice
and today we're talking and then he's
like starts laughing and i'm just like
yeah that's how that would go if i tried
to do that so then i drove three and a
half hours out into the woods
looking for the hippocari of
karoki monster they said it was out
there
it's kind of like kind of like the swamp
thing monster
and i got out there and it scared the
[ __ ] out of me
that's that's that's how you do the
whole show like that he did this
really long my favorite quiet time that
he did was he was telling this really
really long story about him driving out
uh into the everglades and like all the
[ __ ] weird nose and he even had like
the
the google maps [ __ ] so he could like
show where he was and everything
i don't know why that one's so energy
sometimes like if i'm just like chilling
out and i'm
drunk and i don't really feel like
listening like paying attention anything
like sometimes i'll put that on the
background so i've seen it like i've
seen it like 10 times
he has like such a great voice it's like
so relaxing
people are starting to pile in you got
sabrina in there what's up sabrina
dj maniac don the dom the bomb david
june's with us
sandra is here and her now she speaks
jive fluently oh
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know why it just and sandra
dj
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
for those who do not know who sandra is
sandra's my german peanut butter
ambassador
she's this kind of [ __ ] chick that
runs around in a tube top
flat chested
yeah and she goes she goes runs around
and tells all the germans how good
peanut butter is i was
i introduced peanut butter to germany
but she's my peanut butter ambassador
100 years from now when peanut butter is
like
germany's national national sport uh
sports national national [ __ ]
shredder
national food let me [ __ ] go come
here
national sports yeah
yeah but what happens in 20 years it'll
be what a statue of her
no well yes that well maybe there'll be
a statue like both of you it's like
that's how thank you mr roboto tarzan
versus conan hand to hand
only knives who wins conan i think conan
who's playing tarzan though are we
talking about just the metaphysical
tarzan it's just
the metaphysical yeah but then that
could be anybody
it doesn't necessarily have to who
played tarzan johnny why is mueller who
else
played [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] cup he
played tart he's the only person that i
know that play
conan was from you know he was he was
tarzan before
tarzan all right we're talking about
back in samaria
all right another time and it it now
there could
some people oliver stone he imagined the
universe of conan
of samaria what was the name of that
world the hibornia
i think
yeah roger stone imagined that being
post-apocalyptic way in the future
so that there was mutants like
dog-headed people and stuff and
giant spiders and [ __ ] big lizards
and everything you know that i'm gonna
make cat head
mutants yeah that's what i want
[Laughter]
psychic abilities but they would i would
see them as magic abilities please
yeah i should say this uh this coming
saturday well actually i think friday
and saturday at mannequins is goth
apocalypse
so everybody's supposed to do like mad
max yeah they did steampunk last week
but i forgot
yeah so i just wore my regular [ __ ]
sanders in there a lot
laughing dj maniac says you look like
you just played eight holes
who me yeah you and now he's doing the
golf commentator doing a golf
commentator voice
yeah what do i have i gotta change it up
should i change it up
so that just goes [ __ ] straight
riddick on you [ __ ] people
oh you don't have your sexual terrain
that's where i got that right there now
i don't have the transom sexual
tyrannosaur goggles today
i got my [ __ ] guys i got
yeah i'd put a [ __ ] wig on with this
man wow we've only been on like five or
ten minutes and you're already putting a
wig on
cause you're [ __ ] with me we'll have
to [ __ ] with you more than
[ __ ] with me i swear to god we're not
like drunk yet
we're already cooking up there i think
this is only just i got this on
backwards
but i think you got it i'm gonna leave
it i'm gonna leave it on
your robert plant like a [ __ ]
yeah hold on we'll flip it around
well hang on the like wigs usually they
usually have like straps in there that
strap together at the back of your head
yeah you kind of keep it in there okay
it's universal
it could be one way or the other
look at it it's like it's so bouncy yeah
one problem is that i can't read with
this it's bouncing and behaving
well yeah because you probably can't
[ __ ] see it yeah
what was that [ __ ] talking about who
knows
said now you look like napoleon dynamite
[Laughter]
oh my god wait no it's even but now you
look even more like carrot top
yeah carrot top got jacked too man
he looks um horrifying he looks like a
it looks like he looks like a woman in a
certain way a woman with muscles
not real i don't i'm not sure what he
looks like he did for a while
don't insult women like that yeah just
he was just [ __ ] funny
but he doesn't look like a man either he
looks like bizarre he doesn't he's
he's starting to look like not human
he's edging over into like
weird uncanny valley territory
[Laughter]
it's just [ __ ] great bethina says god
i need a wig
they're fun they're fun just changes
change your [ __ ] up [ __ ] 100 percent
just totally yeah i need to change your
whole appearance i haven't worn my green
one in a long time because you didn't
like it
you didn't like it which one's the green
one the long the green one i liked the
green yeah i liked the gray one
i just thought the blue one was better
well the blue one the blue one is the
best one
because that's like that's like black at
the top and then it goes down and it's
like straight and blue at the bottom and
i like that one a lot
i got the wig on over my goggles like i
said that's like this
it's like super funny look at it it's
like [ __ ] crazy
mr robot i said you should look like
carrot top's parents
ronald mcdonald mcdonald's
oh my god i love it yeah dj maniac says
carrot top looks ridiculous
yeah and as bad as his act is he makes
money because of a residency in vegas
see people in vegas why is that a thing
like people there will watch
anything it's just kind of and vegas is
kind of like the
what's that other place that's in
[ __ ] um
branson branson missouri which is kind
of like the vegas for
the midwest type of thing like that's a
tear down
but it's a similar kind of like circuit
that you're on i didn't even really know
like he still does a show in vegas holy
crap
it must be all the [ __ ] like free
liquor at the casinos and everyone's
just
going with no sleeping they must be
looking to watch anything
the only like good thing that was that
that was in vegas last time i checked
was penn and teller
you know what i mean they had a show
there a long time i don't know if they
do anymore
because i used to watch [ __ ] draft
disaster says goth point yeah there's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ton of goth for
of course there's porn of everything
point of everything there's porn of
everything
a lot of those a lot of those porn stars
kind of like the b
level porn stars they were [ __ ] they
were goth before they were in porn
um you can go way back to the 90s
belladonna was a goth chick she was from
[ __ ] biloxi
yeah and she was goth but then she kind
of
she would just be whatever you know she
was an actress too you know in the in
the industry so
she would just dress up as anything she
changed a little bit over time
um one of them
one of the famous one was used to hang
out the castle all the time
we saw her i didn't know i didn't know
who she was though at the time
uh what was her name oh [ __ ] no i can't
remember um
she doesn't live here tomorrow she moved
away uh
she's known for having a really [ __ ]
long time almost like gene simmons
i couldn't that doesn't help me
i could find her name jack says speaking
of hair jenny if you knew what i'm
willing to do to have the ginger hair
you have naturally i've dyed it ginger
before and it looks damn good on me well
yeah [ __ ]
i know so that's the thing it's like i i
sometimes
consider um growing the hair out
to my natural color which is like a
coppery
reddish orange but i'm scared that it's
just gonna be gray
and it's not gonna be pretty like it
used to be so it's like
i don't know and it'll look so crappy
like in there will be a long period of
time when it'll look like really crappy
because i'll have like it'll be black
and then it'll be like
so i don't know what i'm gonna have to
wear a wig that whole entire time until
it grows back out i guess i could just
shave it all off
see i don't have that's one thing i'm
jealous of tom because he has a good
like head like for shaving right
you look good with a shaved head a lot
of times
i would like to shave off all my hair
because my hair is a pain in the [ __ ]
ass and it gets
all over the house he was mopping the
floor the other day
and he's like all over this house it's
just long black hairs
yeah and i was like i can't it's like i
know it's gross it's annoying
it gets stuck in the shower shower drain
every time i wash it every time i brush
it every single
big [ __ ] clumps come out and yet it
never gets any thinner
like so there's always just more of it
and it just
like reproduces overnight it's just like
that [ __ ] story from body bags man
well like with the [ __ ]
aliens that look like hair i kind of
feel like that's what my hair is like
and it gets
everywhere everywhere i found her
larkin love she's from the castle
oh yeah i don't really i kind of
remember her maybe
yeah porn star named larkin love
better than larp and love yes
yeah karen says everyone's doing gray i
don't know why
yeah that's what she looked like
probably back in the time we would have
been there okay that's a little uh
alarming yeah that's that that's that
tongue
oop it turned off [ __ ] it turned off
no it just i had my hair bleed i had my
hair dyed that color
that same color as hers for a long time
yeah it's a little weird
yeah stacy keith she was the one from
body bags that was growing all the hair
except it was really what happened
nothing oh okay
larping love soon to come yeah that's
gonna that's gonna be like the nerdy
version of that yeah yeah i can't
i remember like a few years ago there
was kind of like a
trend for everyone doing their hair gray
or like silver i guess would be more of
a thing
silver or white which on some people
actually looks kind of cool
i don't know if i i don't know if it
would look good on me though i
i bleached my hair blonde one time
before
i did the red because my hair used to be
dyed red it wasn't a wig like this
is and i don't know it looks kind of
neat like i took a couple pictures of it
just because it looked weird and i was
just kind of like
not used to seeing myself with that
color hair but
i don't know i don't know if it's just
kind of like the red it's like
when you bleach it it's just too hard to
[ __ ] maintain man because then you
get like the [ __ ] dark roots and it
looks kind of bad so
and bleach is like super super bad for
your hair so
i don't know i don't know
zach says uh i looked up the castle on
google earth and the first pick i saw of
the interior
was a panorama of a guy in clown makeup
fondling a chicks boobs on a table
that sounds like the castle all right
there's a lot of actually good pictures
of uh the interior of the place is
super super cool i mean it's a big place
it's big
it's pretty much like it's kind of hard
to it's because
ybor city is sort of like the sort of
club
and entertainment district of tampa and
it's old you know what i mean it's kind
of like there's old there's restaurants
there's mall there's all kind of [ __ ]
um that's where like old cigar old cigar
factories used to be in [ __ ] like that
the castle i think used to be what the
[ __ ] was that it was like some kind of
uh what do they call that when they go
and like meet there and have those weird
like [ __ ]
i thought it was a um like a masonic
lodge i think it used to be a masonic
lodge like back in the day somebody said
it was a place where they did
they stored barrels but it might have
been it looked like a messianic temple
to me or some masonic
yeah because i thought it had like some
masonic [ __ ] like still carved into the
brickwork or whatever like the cement
that's over whatever
it is and it's yeah and it's so it's
like it's two stories the bottom
floor over here like in one half of it
they have just like a bar
and the bar is super awesome they have
this bar that goes all the way around
and it's got like it's made of like
black glass or like black rock or
something and they have like
little like river things like carved in
there you know what i mean
it's like it's really really beautiful
so they have that in one half
and then here's the door where you come
in and then on the other half is their
dungeon so they have a bunch of cages
you can go in they have like a bunch of
play areas so you can do that kind of
[ __ ]
and then upstairs is the big uh
dance floor so it's just like this big
huge dance floor a big huge stage
um they have like columns that they have
like dance like go-go dancers on
they have like big screens everywhere
and they're always showing like videos
and like weird old movies and [ __ ] like
that
and uh they have another massive [ __ ]
bar in there which i just like it's kind
of like l-shaped but it's like
are you shaped i can't remember we
haven't been there in a while and then
it used to be like when i used to go
there back in the
90s or like early 2000s they used to
have it was kind of more gothy where
they had like these old like velvet
couches and [ __ ] like that
but they took a lot of that stuff out so
they could put more s
m [ __ ] in there so now there's like a
big cage in the corner
it's got a bunch of floors i think it's
got three floors
well it's two floors it's two floors one
of them yeah but they're really big but
then
dungeon is a little bit lower than the
other one yeah and then out back there's
a patio with a different dj
like a big patio yeah
and they have like stained glass windows
and [ __ ] like that we haven't been in a
while
when's the last time you and tom been to
vegas i have never been to vegas no
i don't think haven't i ever been no i
haven't i don't know i've never been
there
no i haven't either um zach says if you
guys could build a house in any style
what would it be
why are you asking some crazy [ __ ] like
that that's a cool question
i wanted
yeah i want dracula's castle that would
be a victory that's what i want
southern victorian or a [ __ ] old
[ __ ] victor of old southern
plantation house
yeah see i would love it every time we
see those like creepy old movies from
the 70s and like they go like the legacy
and stuff i'm like what are they doing
in my house i want that house
i love that old [ __ ] man that's like
super cool the haunted mansion
in uh california the one in disney
disneyland
uh the outside of that thing it's a it's
like a louisiana plantation house yeah
that's what it looks like
but the one here is like a stone yeah it
looks like an old haunted house
yeah it looks yeah which i like that i
like that better yeah
it i don't know there was something
about the the plantation house
because i had been growing up you know
going
half the time in the south i'd been
seeing houses like that so it was a lot
more down to earth and realistic to me
you know that was a house that you can
see well that was kind of brought it a
little bit that was kind of their idea
with it they said they didn't want it
they said they wanted it to kind of
blend in because i've read like a whole
bunch of books about it because we did
like that show
a while back and i still have that one
about the disney world one that i
haven't read yet
but he said that was one of the things
that they they said they didn't want it
to look like a haunted house from the
outside they just wanted us to look like
a regular house
and then once you got in there it was
like on it every time i go back to the
south and see those whole big old
[ __ ] plantation houses like it there
you get that damn
feeling like oh that's just spooky yeah
yeah i don't know i kind of were though
if you ever went into that [ __ ] they
were [ __ ]
big there was no way to really air
condition them
they had real tall ceilings with fans um
i imagine they've all been retrofitted
now probably with interior
aac because the people that still own
them and and able to have the money to
keep them up
if they weren't destroyed in katrina uh
they were able to
probably air condition them but they
were just weren't built for that they
didn't have the insulation
i mean you'd be too glad if you had the
money
you'd be crazy not to put central air in
there like first
thing you know yeah but they weren't
really made for it
i know but and uh yeah it would cost a
lot of money that's what i'm saying if
you had the money to do it
the walls weren't very thickly insulated
um
they had a lot of glass the ceilings
were really tall
it by the time the the 80s had rolled
around the 70s had rolled around they
all had electric fans installed and most
of the stuff looked like electric fans
from the 40s
you know what i mean a lot of it was
exterior yeah the the metal the
the the conduits the electrical conduits
all that stuff was exterior to the walls
and it wasn't interior because it had
all been retrofitted this ship was
[ __ ] you know
over 100 something years old they
you walked along the floors and they
creaked
yeah i mean there was a lot of hand work
and stuff
but it was all wood and humidity got to
all that [ __ ]
bugs too if you had termites you were
[ __ ]
well yeah and uh
some of the smaller ones that i was some
of the smaller victorians i've been in
because of the warping of some of the
wood in certain areas things like ants
got in a lot
so you're just gonna have to deal with
[ __ ] like ants getting in
the constant war against keeping bugs
out
because they could just get in well yeah
did nothing sealed up
um but that's the way the south was
the old south was uh not fit for [ __ ]
humans human habitation that's why all
this [ __ ] going on where these
big energy companies and these real
estate people that are investing all
this money
into the south and all these people
saying well we're going to have to like
put smart meters on your on all our
buildings and uh
that way to keep the power consumption
down we'll
you'll have to live in 81 degrees in
there man that's just going to go over
like a [ __ ] fart in a spacesuit
that will not they don't know the south
because they don't live here
a house at 81 degrees just won't last
long here
well the walls will be wet yeah they
don't understand how many
these are people that live in new york
and california
that made their life sitting behind
desks
they went to school that's that's their
that's their introduction to world to
the world
um no they don't understand the elements
you have you you build these big houses
down here and keep them at 81 degrees
10 years later that thing will be
[ __ ] rotten
yeah they'll just be right yeah that
[ __ ] beat
floor will [ __ ] smell like [ __ ]
because your carpets [ __ ] rot
everything will have a [ __ ] thick
sheet of [ __ ] mold um
things will start to warp bugs will get
in
rain will get in because the air
conditioning isn't really so much about
keeping it cool it's also about keeping
it dry
yeah that's the [ __ ] one of the main
things
and i've got all that humidity yeah and
air conditioning kills
all these [ __ ] frogs and lizards that
get in i find dead frogs in here all the
time a little bit of
tree frogs i don't know how they got in
here just find a deal probably
brought them in in her mouth i don't
think so i think they come in underneath
the doors
yes they get into a sliding glass door
and they get into a door track and get
in when you're sliding in
the doors or they're in a door and you
you open the door you don't see it but
it jumps in the house because it was on
the other side of the
door you know what i mean because the
doors swing in
although every now and then we've caught
pokey
she'll be outside she'll bring someone
and then she'll
come in the house and she'll look real
she she'll look real shifty
and then she'll like run into the living
room and we're like what's in your mouth
and like you find it and she has like a
little frog or something she's like i
was it was my friend i brought him in
here to play with
but i'll fr i'll find frogs that'll look
alive and you pick it up and it's
dehydrated like a piece of beef jerky
and that's the air conditioner that did
that to them and it only does it in a
few days
and then because they're just not built
for air conditioning
they're built to be at a real high
humidity they can't
be in a dry area and it's the same with
the lizards i've seen
found lizards just crawling across the
floor in slow motion
help help me help me and i'll [ __ ]
grab him like that and try to put water
in his mouth you never really can bring
them back that
just be like little skeletons because
they're just dry it up
yeah air conditioning just somehow just
sucks all the moisture out of them
evil or mafia says if so if you go on
vacation do you turn off the air
conditioner or leave it on you leave it
on
you leave it on you leave it on um i
don't know anybody that would turn it
off so you might turn it up a couple
degrees just to save some money because
you're not there
but i would not turn it off because when
you get back you'll have mold all over
everything
all your pictures will start being
warped your posters and [ __ ] a lot of
work all your books and [ __ ] will be
[ __ ]
you open they'll get thicker
the book will get thicker and the pages
will all be wrinkled yeah man it's 100
humidity
and a lot of people don't understand
what that does it's a hundred percent
humidity
it's like vietnam 100 humidity and in
the dead of the [ __ ] summer you're
talking about 100 degrees
sometimes more it's satan's ass crack
pretty much yeah i was at so
when i was at because when i was in st
augustine and a lot of the [ __ ] that i
wanted to do
like i didn't want to drive so i was
just like walking around so i took like
a [ __ ] ton of like sunblock
because i knew i'd be walking around
outside a lot so when i went to the
alligator farm um
i knew that all of that was outside i
mean pretty much all of that's outside
so i got to a point where i was just i
was there for hours and hours
and i think i sweated through my clothes
like three times
yeah but after a while like it bothered
me but it didn't bother me because i was
just kind of like well there's nothing i
can do about it
so i just kind of got real zen about a
lot of people brought
uh umbrellas which was actually a good
idea because that would keep like the
sun off you i had one too but i didn't
want to like hit other people in the
face so i didn't
i didn't do it but i'm pretty hardcore
you know army infantry korea
been [ __ ] real hot environments like
korea during the summer
real cold like korea in the winter 40
degrees below zero
we're just real humid we hit that
hurricane hit us a couple years back we
lost power for about three or four days
this house was [ __ ] miserable [ __ ]
miserable
being outside was a relief you'd go
outside it was even better
out inside was worse because it's just
still air
and uh it smelled bad smell terrible in
here and just [ __ ]
the walls were wet damp everything was
like wet
yeah the cats are looking that's like
why don't you turn the ac on what's the
matter what the [ __ ] is wrong
the cats are just miserable [ __ ] why are
you doing this to us we're covered with
hair yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah they were blaming us like
we didn't do it
thank you esther love you jenny and tom
we love you too
thank you you're pretty bad 14 super
chat thank you 14.99 14.99
we got some hemp cigarettes this smoked
one all right
these things here ran out of those
herbals so i got some of these hemp ones
they don't get you high or anything do
you want me to order more of the
more of the other ones the thing is
those are 12 bucks
yeah pretty expensive i like these
better but
i will say the herbal ones that i had i
think it's only like eight or nine bucks
for three packs
yeah i'd rather have that probably
because these have one downside
they stink man [ __ ] the smell
well see this is why i buy three packs
of febreze
yeah every time i buy one brings i buy
three packs of febreze
mr robotta says jenny i think the cat
and the frogs have a deal so the cat
lets him in maybe
she brings it like she doesn't kill him
it's weird because she i mean she's like
we got elya in the in the
well hey aaliyah is a young little 18
year old
god check that [ __ ] we met at
mannequin at mannequins and uh jenny
hooks we know her in real life
yeah her boyfriend has got one of those
stature liberty punk rock haircuts out
like they're just a young couple that
live together
it's good to see you elia that's who i
was i think we're gonna have leon as a
guest one and her and her boyfriend on
as a guest one of these days
yes she's local she just lives here in
the area because we met them a couple
weeks back i think i mentioned this on
the show before but i was like before we
met them
i saw the two of them and he had a
christian death shirt on and
he was clearly like a kid he's like 18
or 19 and i was like hooray
the kids are all right she says looking
at a spider the size of a grain of sand
right now how i miss you guys
and then sandra goes hi young got chick
let me remind you something sandra is
one
is the only german girl i've ever known
that speaks jive
fluently
stewardess i speak excuse me stewardess
i speak jive hang loose
barbara billingsley
what's up blood i mean
that was like the [ __ ] best i kind of
feel like if she comes
don't want no help jumbo don't get them
as nick ain't got no breeze in hell
[ __ ] hilarious yeah because she was
she was the bee's mom yeah yeah leave it
to be with mom
like i don't i don't really know i don't
know
that movie's still funny i think but
it's like if you lost the context
if you lost the context of that that was
like yeah leave it to me for his mom
i think a lot of young people wouldn't
have any idea who those people were
maybe not so it was like way funnier so
a lot of
a lot of a lot of the [ __ ] jokes that
have been lost
[Laughter]
man now i want to watch airplane again
did we watch we watched airplane 2 the
other day too like the one with the
space shuttle
yeah yeah that's pretty good that was
actually it's not as funny as the first
one but it's still pretty funny
what we've been watching the last couple
nights is [ __ ] river monsters
man i love that [ __ ] on amazon prime you
can like buy
you can buy all the seasons for what i
what are they like seven or eight
dollars right
pat says is that german jive or american
jive that you speak
i'm pretty sure that's afro-american
jive she's
which i'm pretty sure is the same the
world over yeah i would think
i don't know maybe germans have their
own have their own jobs well those those
german girls who were world renowned
uh for for uh being about that bbc okay
[ __ ] every [ __ ] every [ __ ]
brother of mine in the army of a station
in germany they all want to go to
station to germany oh
we gotta get stationed in germany yeah
they liked it
yeah i knew a guy i knew a girl that i
used to work with that wasn't uh
i mean he was stationed in germany he
loved it there yeah
yeah black guys wanted to be stationed
in germany if they were into white girls
[Laughter]
dj maniac says uh i don't think we have
german jive i'm still learning most of
the slang
i'm fascinated by like slang from
different countries
i just [ __ ] love that i mean i really
really like british slang
i think their slang sounds so much
better than ours i don't know why
it's just i don't know all that cockney
rhyming's lying and all that stuff like
that [ __ ] so [ __ ] funny
sandra's laughing going top yeah yeah
i'll see i'll see you on the in the i'll
see you on your ir
on your ir [ __ ] you're on your
interracial [ __ ] only fans page
uh babe granthar's hammer says when i
was a kid calling someone to jive turkey
was a huge insult
yeah i remember like the i don't know
you're a little bit older than me but
not that much older i remember the tail
end of that
where you called somebody a jive turkey
yeah and that was just like
man there was what was that [ __ ]
movie that i watched on mst the other
day
uh that was that one that's set in the
70s about the [ __ ]
ben murphy driving the truck before my
blow up
and he was calling everybody turkeys and
i just thought that was like so [ __ ]
funny
e4 mafia says i was stationed at panzer
casserine outside stuttgart
okay well there you go
yeah he must have been a american gi
he said his e4 mafia we didn't really
have e4s when i was in
well we did have an e4 e4 was a corporal
i was a spec for e4 what i don't think
was a real
uh rank during the time that i was in it
was a temporary rig
corporal never saw it
yeah that was an e5 in training you were
like a corporal for like
a month or two and then they sent you
off the [ __ ] was it nco school
i only knew one guy that was stationed
in germany i used to work with him
then he became a cop later um elias says
i will never forget all the boobs i saw
in germany you went to germany elia come
on man you how old were you five
are you ahead of me you must be ahead of
me yeah yeah there you go
okay yeah okay i'm a couple seconds
behind you maniac says
e5 was as high as anyone went in gi joe
unless they were top bret
unless they were top brass i don't know
exactly what to talk about e4 was the
pay grade yeah e4 was the pay grade i
guess yeah
yeah yeah dom the bomb says cockney
rhyming slang was standard growing up in
london
i was really proud of myself because for
a long time i used to be married to a
british person he wasn't from
england he was welsh actually but i you
know just from
going over there from watching a lot of
british movies and kind of being
immersed in
the culture like that sometimes i would
see a movie
with somebody speaking like cockney
rhyming slang in it and i'd be able to
figure it out all by myself and i was
like
be really proud of myself that i could
figure it out
because it's like really convoluted but
i love that kind of [ __ ] i love language
i'm a writer you know what i mean so
tom's gi joe figure name would be what
oh that's a good one
i'm trying to think of like all because
my brother had a whole bunch of those gi
joe figures back
what was the one he was yellow and red
and he was like i've had a
he was like a firefighter type of dude
what was that [ __ ] what was that
fucker's name
god damn it you didn't have any gi joe
figures uh no not really
really i had the original gi joes they
were big well yeah the big like barbie
sizes but that was just gi joe
yeah you didn't have like the little no
the little ones my brother had a bunch
of the little i was too old for that
like i said when those came out i was
already in high school okay yeah
because i'm i'm three or four years
younger than you and my brother is four
years younger than me
so he had them but i just remember
i had the big giant yeah that's what
they started as
yeah it's funny because if you guys ever
watch uh
on netflix they have like that show the
toys that made us and i think they did a
whole show on gig didn't they
and gi joe was basically an outgrowth of
because barbie was such a big
deal it was a boy bar they were like
let's make a boy barbie like with army
[ __ ] on it
right well then they knew how to sell it
yeah but they would not call it a doll
see they were very smart and they said
we are not going to call this a doll
this is an action figure
yeah that went to barbie just sits
around he does [ __ ] yeah
and i wanted g.i joe when i was a kid
this is back in the 70s and it wasn't so
much
because of the the figure it was for the
guns that he came with
and the vehicles because he had a
six-wheeled vehicle you could run
you could have him yeah my brother had
that yeah he had the excavation stuff to
pull out the [ __ ] mummy out of the
ground with egyptian sarcophagus
he had a [ __ ] submarine you could go
like that it would sink down into he put
him in remember that orange the yellow
submarine
that he had and then we all live in one
no
no it was kind of like a it was kind of
like a submarine a rescue submarine
you know what i mean it was yellow
though i think it was it was either
yellow or orange i know i just laughed
that you said yellow submarine
yeah i didn't i didn't take the bait the
uh
it had it had all kinds of cool [ __ ]
you're not funny no i know anything
blowtorch that was his name
yeah dj maniacs you got a new symbol
yeah
so boys didn't buy it for the figure
for the mo for the most part and or it
was the guns and the
vehicles and all the accessories
because i remember playing more with the
vehicles and the guns the little guns
that i did with the actual
the actual joe the [ __ ] doll
yeah weird but not really i put him in
it but
then you'd run him around and you know
what i mean and here
get in there
and then and they knew how to they knew
how to sell that to boys
yeah the one set that i had you could
make a big
tower out of these plastic girders and
you had a rope that went from the top
and you could
connect it somewhere and you he could
hold on to something you could slide him
down the rope
that also i i don't remember what that
thing was called
you don't remember that that was before
your time my time is
about the same time as your time it was
it was [ __ ] gi joe with the kung fu
grip
yeah he had a kung fu grip yeah because
normal grip is not enough you're gonna
have that kung fu
grip sure because kung fu has got a
slightly different grip than other grips
when you think about it like what the
[ __ ] because when i think of kung fu
yeah i think of somebody doing that yeah
right yeah that's not a grip
it's not a grip you don't it's fighting
but there's a certain
kind of grip that only a martial artist
has
sure it didn't make any [ __ ] sense
then and it doesn't make any sense now
well no one really thought about it
they're like oh concrete grip okay
yeah it was awesome
it was emotion happy birthday oracle
awesome so does tom have the kung fu
grip
no he does not have no i have normal
grip i got the conan grip
[Laughter]
kung fu kung fu is [ __ ] soy as [ __ ]
kung fu is the fantasies of a 140 pound
man
that's what kung fu is you see don't get
me [ __ ] started i know you [ __ ]
are in there because they got these
dudes that are the same age as me
and they grew up just like i did
watching those kung fu movies
with and not having the internet and not
really knowing what was true
wasn't true and yes we were fooled by
kung fu for a while
it was easy well i don't even know if
i'd say it was easier to fool people
back then because
it's still pretty easy to fool people
nowadays it's even easier back then
but i think it was easier back yeah
which that's pretty crazy because like
people are still idiots nowadays but
it's like back then
it was like much easier because you
couldn't check what are you gonna do
call the library
we don't have the internet we should get
that black belt magazine
all right we'd be we'd go to 7-eleven
we're drinking [ __ ] playing spy
hunter
playing galaga [ __ ] rastan and [ __ ]
like that
and behind yeah getting butthorn
fall on the [ __ ] butt
behind us would be the [ __ ] magazine
rack
and then have all kinds of magazines
like assault weapons and [ __ ] swat
and [ __ ] guns and ammo guns of damage
was boring though we like the good [ __ ]
like [ __ ] gundam
is kind of important it's [ __ ] boring
we soldier a fortune magazine you know
[ __ ] and in soldier fortune magazine
was mercenary stuff and kung fu [ __ ] but
they also had one called black belt
yeah so we'd be [ __ ] drinking
slurpees and [ __ ]
big gulps and [ __ ] watching girls walk
in you know [ __ ]
commenting on the [ __ ] booty and
stuff you know playing spy hunter
and uh not that much different to now
it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and you know we grew up on a diet of
watching these
[ __ ] martial arts movies
and not knowing what was true so you see
the [ __ ] in movies and then you see it
in print
and you see black belt magazine and you
have all these [ __ ] senseis and all
these [ __ ] masters and [ __ ] and
they're
making these [ __ ] wild claims that
they can do this and that they can
[ __ ] defeat twenty
two are you like not even touching you
yeah [ __ ] they gotta cheat on the
chee ball hitting you with [ __ ]
chee balls cheap power which is obvious
yeah yeah one inch punch death touches
yeah poison handshake but it sounded
cool the dim mock
you know and all this kind of stuff you
know
sierra [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] oh
yeah
come on right back to bush for more
information
and there was some appealing about all
that
because there were all these little
offers if you [ __ ] pay this amount of
money we'll send you this video
from like a sheet of kim fake ninja
you know or just some [ __ ] like that
seriously if the church
go on youtube and do a search for a
shooter cam and watch some of that dudes
videos
they're so hilarious slash pathetic at
the same time
that'd be something like a child like us
would have [ __ ] the kids like us
would have got that [ __ ]
i'll pay the twenty dollars to get the
videos you know yeah i didn't have
twenty dollars though so
yeah we would try to scrape it together
to get the [ __ ] secret to the death
but i wanted to see
monkeys though so i'm you know i'm not
much better
we weren't that young we were like 16
17. 15 16 17.
this [ __ ] was ridiculous though yeah
it was before the internet you couldn't
verify anything
there was no comment section on anything
too
so you were on your own about how you
you're you'd read something and you were
on your own your your reaction might be
i don't know
about that but if there was a comment
section the comment was
like this dude is so full of [ __ ] and
then there'd be all kinds of you know
then it'd be links to [ __ ] with
somebody else you know
and then oh he's full of [ __ ] you know
and that would go like yeah it's gotta
be
gotta be [ __ ] you know but we didn't
we didn't grow up that way we didn't
have that
you know i mean so you just were kind of
out there on your own going yeah maybe
maybe that maybe you can do something
like that maybe you can kill people just
by touching them in a certain place well
you know i came from a kind of a special
background too you know i saw a [ __ ]
poltergeist
this is before the time that i had
out-of-body experiences or anything like
that but
i saw that poetry guys so i thought that
maybe
maybe chi energy might have had
something to do with that
maybe you could so what you're talking
about it's like something out of damn
star wars because you had seen it so
to you it seemed more plausible a little
bit more plausible right
but the guys that they're quoting
okay there was no video available of
them until much much later you know i
mean
uh history channel and national
geographic started exposing these kind
of these guys you know
like dillman remember dillman the guy
from the the the no touch knockout
oh yeah yeah that guy yeah we talked
about him and dillman was like a
respected martial artist
supposedly really well known i mean
he even trained muhammad ali
so damn it's got to be true but
i guess you could say information was
very narrow banned
back then you were seeing everything in
isolation from something else
now we have like a broadband information
you can look up dillman and then
everything about dillman and then
everything everybody said about dillman
and then you can see dillman's
interactions with other people
if those actually exist so all of a
sudden you go oh no this dude's full
[ __ ]
but it was it was a lot harder to
defraud someone back then
if they were in print or they were in
video then it kind of gave him
credibility
well yeah because nobody else was well
because it was much harder
harder to get into print right because
like i said we didn't have the internet
it was like a magazines and they were
expensive to produce
so it's like well there must be
something to it if they printed it
wasted the time to
put this [ __ ] in the magazine
then that must be true
right you know what i mean that's what
we're thinking oh no but there was just
some so much crazy [ __ ] with it with the
with martial arts
in a way though you have to well you
don't have to but you can kind of admire
in a [ __ ] up way some of the people
back then
that twigged on to the fact that like no
one can check on my [ __ ] so i can pretty
much just like make up whatever i want
right and i mean some of these people
went really really far
and got like really respected like you
said and they turn up in like big you
know when we're just talking about black
belt magazine
they would turn up in the magazine it's
like they you would get [ __ ]
paid to do demonstrations and [ __ ] yeah
so you could pretty much [ __ ] your
way into almost anything
but again if you had enough conviction
in what you were saying
there were a lot of red flags going all
the way back to the 60s
there yeah even the fifties okay
when you had chinese martial arts
masters that would not
teach any westerners no and would then
would not even allow westerners to fight
them
this goes back in the sixties of the 70s
then you know that there's
that that strange things are afoot at
the circle k
[Laughter]
oh my god i've heard them remember that
yeah you know strange things right
that's a circle because they won't fight
you and they have to make
excuses why they won't fight you well
the reason why they wouldn't fight you
and this even comes up today you can you
can just go on youtube and go
and go mma fighter fights
i think it's kung fu master or a wushu
master
and it's a chinese martial arts guy or a
mixed martial arts guy mma fighter
who's trying to bring mma into china and
he was
posting in chinese social media look man
these wushu guys
and all this [ __ ] kung fu master [ __ ]
they're full of [ __ ]
fight me and i'll show you they're full
of [ __ ] well
they this guy's maybe 30 years old and
really good [ __ ] condition
he's an mma fighter his rules are his
rules are just
rule number one win okay yeah when
all right that's that's the first rule
like try not to kill the dude right
but when all right and then he [ __ ]
some
one of these chinese martial arts guys
says okay i'll take the challenge and
he's one of these no touch knockout
dillman type and he's a
he's maybe 130 pounds
late 50s maybe 130 pounds
and uh maybe five five all right so did
the mma guy like
oh he cleaned the [ __ ] floor with the
dude did he wipe
his ass with him just walked up at the
end
just walked out just [ __ ] punched him
knocked him on the ground [ __ ] beat
on him a little bit dude got back up
they separated him he didn't did it like
twice all right second time he kicks a
dude in the [ __ ] head and [ __ ]
[ __ ] beats on him a little bit
and just that no touch wushu [ __ ] didn't
work because that dude just beat his ass
you can't use mind powers when people
are beating your ass
you know that's what happened just beat
his head that's a good tip for life in
general right
so this dude beats his [ __ ] ass all
right
in front of all of china and the entire
[ __ ] chinese social media goes after
this [ __ ] mma fighter how dare you
disrespect china
ain't that some [ __ ] how dare you
disrespect china with your american
fighting style
like what yeah and this he was begging
okay okay people you know i'm just
trying to show you that it's not real
you know he was crying and
crying he should have stood his ground
but i can understand you know [ __ ] he
had the ccp and all of chyna
calling him a scumbag for beating the
dude up well he took the accept of the
challenge
it was a fight got his ass whipped well
that's the thing i mean you'd think that
it's what it says on the tent it's like
yeah we're gonna fight right yeah
but i'm not just gonna like touch you
but in china and the mentality of china
kung fu is supposed to win even though
kung fu does not [ __ ] work
mma works and there's chinese they'll
just like beat the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of you okay and uh
that was what that that takes me back to
[ __ ] bruce lee
because that's what bruce lee was saying
if you go back to all the bruce lee's
bruce lee was
he could fight chuck norris was a real
fighter
chuck norris saw bruce lee and trained
with him they kind of sparred he said
bruce lee was good
but bruce lee was not a fighting he was
not a professional fighter he was an
actor
but if he was a fighter he would have
done very well that's
out of bruise chuck norris's mouth the
chuck norris
became an actor later on but chuck
started off as a
fighter okay he he did full contact
kung fu or you know martial arts
competitions
now mma had not
been invented yet there were certain
rules all this [ __ ] goes back to the
kumite and all you [ __ ]
little young boys growing up in the 80s
know that exactly what i'm talking about
with takumate and [ __ ] what was the
name of that goddamn [ __ ] movie that
worked
for the bloodsport yeah yeah okay
bloodsport was about mma it's just the
mma didn't exist yet
okay yeah i don't even remember hearing
about mma until at least then
no it started with ultimate fighting and
then it became yeah
yeah and ultimately i remember ultimate
fighting came and i was like oh man
[ __ ] this is the end of the [ __ ]
world man how dare can you how can you
have
fights without any rules get out of it
well the rule is just don't kill the
dude just win you know what i mean
or at least try not to kill the deal
yeah it happens accidentally yeah
i mean there's certain things you can't
do you know you can't bite and [ __ ] you
know but you know
there were some reasons that's just it
wasn't boxing
and my generation grew up during the
kind of the era of boxing
and into the martial arts and that was
kind of
both boxing and martial is kind of
[ __ ] even
even um because you're too limited in
boxing you can't kick
and you can't grapple and wrestle which
that's that's not the way a fight really
happens plus the balls are off limits
okay you're right yeah
anyway i'm [ __ ] getting ahead of
myself dj maniac says tom has now been
off the rails for 20 minutes so please
have him check his dms
lol oh yeah he was telling me a long
time ago to like check it out to check
my message i'll be i will on a minute
dude hold up i'll remind you in a minute
[Laughter]
bruce lee
his little monologues and everything he
was talking about about the ultimate
martial art know one that didn't really
have a style or blended all the things
that worked
he's talking about mma so bruce lee was
a visionary
he was in you know he he was good and
and that's
and that's what bruce lee was talking
about that whole time and it did happen
that was the kumite from bloodsport is
mma
yeah um not quite as cinematic i guess
yeah you're not killing people and [ __ ]
but you know
but people have been killed in boxing
matches well yeah that's yeah that
happens
people have been killed [ __ ] in
football you know that's true also
so and car racing all the time not as
much as it used to be but
i remember when dale earnhardt got
killed i still lived in daytona at that
point
hitting the [ __ ] well but most people
i i was always kind of confused too
you know about bruce lee when i was a
kid was bruce lee a fighter was an actor
was he really that
good he was good he was an actor though
he came from the theater chinese theater
where he had a lot of dabs
but he could fight um he sparred a lot
well he was in really good shape
he was in really good shape he was real
conditioned they didn't [ __ ] around with
like that [ __ ] dance in school and
[ __ ]
because jackie chan went to that show
yeah most people that
know mma know martial arts
and knew what he was like they've all
kind of come to the conclusion that
had he put on about 20 pounds of muscle
he could have gone into mma
under those new rules and done very well
that's what kind of guy he was yeah
yeah i think he probably yeah he could
have done very well i mean he was he was
a little dude but he was in like really
good shape he needed more weight on him
yeah because he was more about speed and
this and that but you could
feed him and [ __ ] do a lot of [ __ ]
weight training and maybe [ __ ] some
hormone therapy put another 20 pounds
out he was like
he was only 145 pounds yeah like i said
he was a little dude right he needed to
be a little bit he was very very lean
and he needed a ground game but he was
the kind of guy by all
accounts he was the kind of guy that
could learn anything
he was very when it came to that kind of
stuff he's very dedicated so you teach
him a ground game
and he he would have learned it and he
would have been real good he's real
innovative real creative
so i don't really talk [ __ ] about um
bruce lee bruce lee was rad yeah he just
seemed like a cool dude all around
yeah he was good uh i'll talk [ __ ] about
[ __ ] you know my boy seagal
somebody asked you earlier to like say
something about the goal yeah
yeah he don't even get us started on
steven we'll give you started on this
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] will come after me
i don't know why you would be a freedom
he's in russia it'd make an awesome
video huh
it would be tom i'm here to tell you
that i've heard everything you said
about me i think you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
if he turned up on our doorstep one day
oh my god that would be so [ __ ] gonna
change that would be so [ __ ] funny
i'm gonna challenge your sawed-off ass
to a fight right now
come on put your [ __ ] on
[Laughter]
put your boots on i told you though if
he did that he would turn up at our
on our front porch and he would
challenge you to a fight and then he
would stand over there
and then he would get his stunt double
to fight you yeah yeah
now he tried to fight i'd get him tired
though that's how i beat him
i just get him to turn and turn and turn
and where what you could do
because he's pretty big is you could
have a donut in your pocket and you
could throw it over there
that you wouldn't go and he would get
the donut right
um you know that's what i mean you know
just about just to back up
seagal is a martial artist but
but um that martial art that he knows is
not a [ __ ] real aggressive martial
it's not that good it's not a fighty one
not really and uh it it is
i'm not i'm not sure that's a what's
that what's that [ __ ] called
that he was using i'm not sure that
that's that's a
it's not aikido is it it's a keto yeah
yeah it's a martial art but i don't
think it's
i don't think it's a useful martial art
i think it's it's it's obsolete
and i mean like i said i'm not like
[ __ ] on martial arts and you know
but we're just talking about if you got
like in a street fight
right that's not what you would use yeah
that's not really effective
he's not a very physically fit or
conditioned guy he never really was he
was very tall he's six foot something
he's got some weight behind the image
he's a big dude he's a big dude
he's not powerful though if you look at
his arms he's not in good condition he's
he's not he can't run
um yeah he can't walk up her downstairs
[Laughter]
he's just he's an actor
if that's what you want to call it he's
an entertainer
yeah he was a [ __ ] cop though for a
while he was sheriff
he wasn't a real cop they just made him
like an honorary
cop because he was famous that's true so
they just like let him go to the [ __ ]
scenes and stuff to make it very
important that's why
somebody asked why we don't have a dog i
don't really like dogs that much do you
i'm not a big yeah i'm not a big dog
like i like dogs
the thing about dogs is that i feel like
they're
you know and pookie is like our child
but dogs are even more like human
children
and i really don't like human children
they're too needy
um pookie is she's kind of needy because
she's just kind of like
let me love you but then she'll be like
yeah [ __ ] you i'm gonna go do my own
thing and that's cool
i like that yeah i was like i was uh
watching a jackson galaxy video today
because that's kind of what i do
and uh one of the comments said that uh
all cats are on the autism spectrum and
i was like
they kind of are though because it's
like they kind of well
the cool thing about cats and the thing
that i like about cats because they're
very similar to me and personality i
guess
is that you know they want affection
they want attention stuff like that but
on their terms
they want to come to you and then at the
end of it they're just kind of like all
right [ __ ] off and leave me alone
that you know what i mean and i relate
to that more i feel like a dog is always
like trying to like please you like
hey what can i do hey what can i do and
that's like really tiresome to me
yeah you know what i mean mr roboto says
does
does uh does steven seagal does he run
does he there's videos of him running
okay
somebody did like a super cut of like
all the [ __ ] up weird runs that he
does
i got to back up on this he runs he runs
so weird
i don't know how long you've been
listening to this show
but me and seagal stories go way back on
this [ __ ] show
all right all right
cigar's a fixture on this show i'm gonna
[ __ ] talk about him sometimes
because i had like a personal history
with [ __ ] segal
in terms of when i was [ __ ] stationed
in sinai peninsula and in the army
[ __ ] at op311 [ __ ] i saw
it was on the mfo mission which some of
you guys in the service know what i'm
talking about
it's a multinational force observers it
was set up by
again president carter to enforce the
peace treaty between israel egypt so i
was down there
and they were we had our own little bar
at south camp they would play
movies there be like movie night
and we kept hearing about this steven
seagalg dude
all right and uh
it was rumored that he was a navy seal
and did and a real [ __ ] martial arts
specialist and [ __ ] so they were
playing the steven seagal movie and i
had to go see it you know
i mean i got to check this out yeah yeah
yeah and they were like oh yeah yeah he
was in the service he was a navy seal
and it's about him planting navy seals
called under siege and it was a pretty
good movie
it had titties in it and everything
the mark of a quality film [ __ ] right
sandra tiller so
i was walked away kind of impressed i
was like yeah it was a good movie man
because
that dude yeah that was pretty
impressive
but then later they played another movie
i think it was called
i think i don't know it wasn't hard to
kill it was yeah that's kind of like
wall
for justice i think it's called alfred
because all of his like movie titles are
just so like
they're all the same yeah they they do
them with like magnets yeah yeah yeah
that have like
the words and they just like rearrange
them around you know what i mean
so i think it was out for justice they
put that one up there and he's wearing a
black [ __ ] ranger army beret you know
and i'm going yeah okay all right we're
watching it and they show a scene with
him running
and he was running and flapping his
wings and [ __ ] and [ __ ] everybody
in
the [ __ ] bar watching it
started laughing he has the weirdest run
because we
all [ __ ] run our [ __ ] asses off in
formation and you
know a military man by the way that
[ __ ] runs
okay he can run all right there is no
man that has ever served at any service
anywhere of any time first like another
runs of
like a [ __ ] and that [ __ ] ran
like a [ __ ]
i don't think i've ever seen and i'm not
a runner really but it's like even i
look less
stupid than he does open another window
open another one go on youtube and just
go
and just just search steven seagal right
it'll probably pop right up oh yeah
yeah and they'll have edits of that
[ __ ] running
okay that is not how a military man
would ever run
that is it's not how a human being is
not how marines are
the only person the only person that has
ever run
like that is a person who who is only
sprinted in front of a camera a couple
of times like that i mean
that's that was probably the first time
i was thinking about it that's probably
the first time that dude has ever run
yeah why don't you run the other okay
and that was the extent of his run and
then they're
it's not a dude that's ever jogged or
run for fitness or anything you know
that dude's never running any distance
at all
okay that was some that was a run he
just pulled out of his ass
tom the mom said his hands flapping like
a chicken yeah dj maniac says he runs
like shatner did in tj hooker yeah
yeah that's another non-running
[ __ ]
says he runs like the beginning of
little house on the prairie when the
ingles girls are running
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know exactly what
you're talking about
so and this is true okay
this is true oh my god i'm dying all all
of the
all of my unit the 327th infantry saw
that run and we all busted up [ __ ]
laughing at the same time
and we were like no it can't be
[Laughter]
no it can't be but there was no way to
check back then
yeah had we been able to do the math and
[ __ ] pulled up his old story that
there would not have been enough time
for him to be
in the navy seals well yeah
you see it's the times were different
back then
if you were going to go into any kind of
special operations all right
which would have been special forces
navy seal any of the big ones you know
sfod which has been delta
but you had to be you recruited [ __ ]
sfod and delta from special forces
usually
as soon as you start as soon as you just
start saying hey would you like to try
out for special forces go through the
[ __ ] selection and then we'll run you
through cue cars
if you make it through all that [ __ ]
well you've basically agreed
to where if you make it you sign on for
20 year contract you're not going
anywhere
you're not gonna get out of service
until you're in your 40s
okay so how the hell are you going to be
and it's the same thing with
a lot of that a lot of that navy seal
type stuff
so how the hell are you going to be a 30
year old
or a 29 year old martial artist x
special forces seal
at 29. what you get kicked out
[Laughter]
because that's a career that's an entire
[ __ ] career
and then you're not gonna be an actor in
hollywood when you get out
that's [ __ ] that's that's [ __ ]
money you're gonna work for a private
security company making about 200 000 a
year
okay that's what which is you're gonna
be a mercenary okay for somebody
or private security for a company you're
going to be a bodyguard for some foreign
president
yeah that's where those guys go now it's
even worse you know if i can for all you
know the [ __ ] are being
assassins you know but
yeah one of the baddest [ __ ]
i'm trying to remember his name right
now he was in [ __ ] all those special
units he now runs a private security
company out of the philippines
and he he creates mercenaries and runs
them
i can't remember his name but he i can't
just just look up
go search this term american badass and
his [ __ ] name will appear
he's about 50 he's about my age and this
[ __ ] is a badass
he got involved in bodybuilding after he
got out of the after he got out of
special forces and
won he only got ready and he got ready
in about a year
he won it and his we didn't win it now
sorry he got fifth place
his son got fourth place his son went in
with him
but this is a dude that is not a
bodybuilder but he became a bodybuilder
in a year
yeah that's dedication why is that so
hard yeah when he like he just went i
can do it i can do that and he did it
red harvest said steven seagal running
is the second
search result that shows up when you
type his name really okay
all right i made that [ __ ] famous that
also does not surprise you
i'm pretty sure it was famous it was
kind of fantastic well
we all noticed everybody noticed
everybody [ __ ] noticed it
sandra says i can't stop watching cigal
running videos now
his arms yeah okay
and that is not the arms
[Laughter]
that is not the arms of an elite warrior
i don't care how tall you are okay that
is not the arms of an elite i don't even
run like that like i said
and i'm a girl and i'm like not even a
runner i don't run like that
holy crap who told him that was okay
yeah see oracle said that too man i'm a
nerd and i better discipline with my
arms when i run right
that's what i'm saying
let me tell you something segal is an
amazing man
sure this is a man that talked his way
into hollywood roles
made him a lot of money impregnated a
lot of women he's got a lot of lawsuits
behind him he had to leave the country
that's he's like an
international [ __ ] he's like an
international secret agent
he even met even if you look at it in a
certain way
i would love to make a [ __ ] movie
about segal
you know i'm sure they will one of these
days yeah he bullshitted his
way into meat and putin yeah and [ __ ]
putin was like who is this [ __ ]
putin put up with it evidently but my
understanding is that
putin figured that he was full of [ __ ]
fourth drawer down says those are the
arms of a man herding ducks
[Laughter]
yeah he's the kind of guy that we go
yeah it's about speed it's about speed
and skill
no it's not no it's not yeah he thinks
he's doing something
like aerodynamics right he'll come up
with some excuses yeah
this is another one i want to tell you
mr robots mr roboto came in and says
well you see
eastern eastern martial artists don't
have to prove
anything to western people dude no they
were they avoided the challenges because
they would get their [ __ ] asses beat
because their martial arts was a scam
it's all it's very easy to take people
who
don't know how to fight and to tell them
these these little [ __ ] that's what
dillman was doing that what's his name
george dilman
his name was was it george or brad or
george
he would just get a random person who
wanted to pay to go into a [ __ ] dojo
club
and and and instead of
going through the work of
building somebody up into a [ __ ]
fighting machine which requires the
proper
diet training blood work
[ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] chemical
assistance
and then a bunch of training and
endurance why do that
when they will pay you to [ __ ] teach
them the one inch punch or the [ __ ]
death touch
which the weakest person in the world
can [ __ ] kill the most ultimate power
the most powerful man you can just boom
and it just kills them they'll pay for
that
because that's the easy way out does it
work no
no but they'll still pay you for it well
yeah
well because everybody wants to think
that there's like some
like cheat code yeah it's a cheap easy
way to do
everything not just you know weight loss
or getting in shape or whatever
yeah it's just everybody wants there to
be like some secret
yeah easy way to do [ __ ] and there's
just no
and is that right no it's wrong [ __ ]
very wrong because what
dillman had was a bunch of very weak
students overweight women
walking around thinking that they had
the power of life and death over [ __ ]
people
thinking that they were well protected
and if they ever got into a jam they
would try to do the little death shot
touch and guess what
and she wouldn't work and he'd get
killed so [ __ ]
is dillman helping him no he's getting
him killed
they're taking their [ __ ] money well
yeah because in a way
it's almost kind of like worse than just
acknowledging hey i'm a weak-ass
[ __ ] that'll get my ass kicked
right if you're because you're giving
them false false confidence and so they
might walk into
situations that they wouldn't have
walked into otherwise
they think that they can they can do it
run up on an armed man and try to do the
damn mock
and you can kill him to take the gun and
see how you get your [ __ ] [ __ ]
blown away okay you should have taken
all that [ __ ] money
all that thousands of dollars that you
spend on those [ __ ] dojos and buy a
[ __ ] gun
that works that would probably work
better that worked a lot better yeah
than trying to go yeah ball at you
unless the person's gonna kill you is
just like what and then that gives you a
chance to run away
but i don't know i wouldn't count on it
if i was you
um oh my goodness oh you've been making
a drink another round go ahead
another round another round i don't even
know we were thinking about going out
after but then i was kind of like
i'm kind of broke after that vacation i
gotta say and we gotta go out on the
saturday and i think we have to go on a
monday too oh my poor liver
but yeah i've been drinking the last
couple nights not a lot i just had a
cocktail last night and the night before
i had a cocktail last night because i
was watching river monsters like i said
um esther was saying earlier we bought
well because we used to watch it on tv
whatever the [ __ ] channel it's on
discovery or whatever and then our
travel channel
and then i kind of lost track of it
and then we're like oh amazon prime has
all of the uh
all of the seasons for whatever they
were like seven eight bucks
and i was like do we even see this
season this doesn't even look familiar
and i was like even if we did see it i
don't remember it so
might as well pay so we paid for it and
we're watching it
and then we like i guess there's like
two or three more seasons that we still
have to watch
um but there as there's something like
really relaxing
i don't know why there's something
really relaxing about river monsters i
guess it's like jeremy wade
and his like sexy ass race man and
looking you know thing that he has going
on
and his voice is kind of relaxing and
i don't know even it's like super scary
like i don't know all the [ __ ] that he
comes up is like super scary there was
one
episode i think it was season eight and
we were just watching it last night
season
seven season eight i can't remember
where
he did a show about
um looking for like parasites
in his own body and then he was kind of
going around like looking like look at
what [ __ ] up [ __ ] these paris the
parasites do to like people's bodies and
[ __ ]
now let's find out if i have any of
these parasites because i've been to all
these locations
and i have a hard time because i guess
like some people on his crew
like turned up with some of these
parasites and so he's like well man i
gotta [ __ ] have these as well even
though he takes all the you know
immunizations and whatnot
but so they kind of like string you
along through the whole episode and they
show you some like super [ __ ] up [ __ ]
man there was like this one woman that
had [ __ ]
a bot fly larva in her head and it like
went into her brain and it like
ended up killing her it was like a
little girl that had [ __ ] uh
worms like in her [ __ ] uh intestines
and they had to take like these big
pieces of
intestines out and they should like the
[ __ ] picture of this [ __ ]
intestine with all these [ __ ] worms
in it it was so [ __ ] gross
they had that they had a dude with like
um elephantiasis
like his [ __ ] one leg was all [ __ ]
swelled up and [ __ ]
it was just like it was super [ __ ] up
so so they have that
and then at the end like jeremy goes
back to liverpool where the you know
tropical diseases clinic is and they've
taken all his blood and his urine and
poop and everything and they're like
trying to figure out if he's got any of
this [ __ ]
and they so they kind of string you
along it's like oh and for this this is
leash maniacist it's like
and you don't have that and he's just
like whew and then like i think the only
thing he ended up having
thank you it was like weed in here yeah
i wonder why that goes
get the breeze it's down there it's okay
hear me smoking
but like the only thing that he ended up
having was um
like a very very mild form of like
amoebic dysentery are you talking about
jeremy wade oh there was that one that
was like it was kind of like a monster's
inside me episode except it was jeremy
wade instead
but they had the one about i was i had
to rewatch the one
the one from season seven or season 8
last night the one about the blue holes
whatever the hell that was and uh what
was like pulling all those divers like
our swimmers like under the water and it
turned out to be well
they think that it maybe was like a big
ass octopus was like just pulling people
down
but yeah there was that kind of thing
going on
yeah pat says i'm staying out of the
tropics honestly it's just kind of like
it's so terrifying because
that show and monster's inside me it's
like i like that show but it's
horrifying and you watch it
and it's just kind of like man i was
just walking down the [ __ ] street one
day like you do
a million times you're in your life and
you get bit by a mosquito
and all of a sudden your brain is
swelling or your
asshole's falling out or whatever it's
just kind of like
it's just it's a horrifying horror i
know it's like it probably won't happen
in this part of the world but
holy [ __ ] dude all right yeah see
what dj maniac showing me the damn
three-wheeled vehicle from
from from gi joe oh yeah yeah the thing
is that's the little one i had the big
one
of course you did yeah that's a little
one that's a little action figure one
i had the one that the big gia joe doll
could fit in
let me see if i can find that i forgot
what that was
i look good though he's pastoring me
about let's see in that
okay let's see what's going on see cam
guy says they say that spiders are
actually responsible for zillions of
zillions of dead insects more than
insecticides
yeah that's true that's why trinidad's
liking tom doesn't like spiders
but um i actually quite like spiders and
i try not to kill them
when i see them in the house because
like i said they eat
mosquitoes and roaches and a bunch of
insects that you don't want
so it's probably better same with snakes
it's like snakes are really
like don't kill snakes if you see one
like in your yard because they
go a long way toward killing like vermin
that spread diseases you know like rats
and stuff
so you know um
yeah karen said the mandating catfish is
the one that got me yeah there's like
been some [ __ ] horrifying catfish on
that [ __ ] the one and then i remember
one too that they
i think it was in the keys somewhere and
uh some fish had been like jumping up in
the boat and like knocking people out of
the boat
and like cutting them open and i was
like dude that's barracudas it's gotta
be
and i was right because barracuda will
jump right in your [ __ ] boat
barracudas are [ __ ] they can't eat
you because they're small
but they have like this really really
sharp teeth and they kind of like
they'll slice you though
and they're heavy enough that if they
jump into your boat they can totally
like [ __ ]
because one woman she was in a boat her
and her boyfriend
and they were in i'm pretty sure it was
the keys somewhere
and uh she didn't know what it was but
this [ __ ] thing jumped out the water
knocked her out of the boat and broke
her rib and like cut
the side like she needed all kind of
stitches and [ __ ]
yeah it was a big-ass barracuda that's
what that was
what you got there there's alya
that's illegal you're still there early
i'm showing you a picture is she still
there you didn't even ask her
it's okay i'm gonna do it anyway
we'll see you saturday you should have
asked for her before you did that oh
[ __ ] she's gonna be all right
she gonna be all right yeah mister she's
gonna be on the show she said she wanted
to be on the show
okay well now you kind of wear yeah
jenny snakes also eat dogs and cats if
they grow too big yeah i know
that um but you know we don't have ones
that big um unless someone's pet python
escapes i've seen that happen before
but the ones that we have in the wild
here are not big enough to eat a dog or
a cat
but i used to get really mad because my
grandma would always you know she'd see
like a harmless snake that wasn't even a
poisonous you know what i mean like a
[ __ ]
you know like a rat snake or something
like that and she was just
she didn't like them so she just like
chopped their heads off with a shovel
and i'm just like god damn it
they eat mice and bugs and [ __ ] like
that
they're good to have a rap know what i'm
saying
yeah you paid attention not really
[Laughter]
what else is this no i'm talking to evan
gotta get back into the stream here
yeah you can't like leave everything to
me
i got you i got man i'm talking about
you no you're not
you went off down on your thing and you
[ __ ] doing your thing well yeah
because you were out there making a
drink so i had to all right
okay let's see what everybody say to my
spiders
i was talking about seeing all those uh
alligators and crocodiles at the
alligator farm
yeah and uh they do like uh they they
have a bunch of like snakes and [ __ ] too
like you could have like a little
reptile house and they have a bunch of
birds and whatnot
yeah fourth jordan says the creatures i
worry about are those that get bigger
and bigger as long as they get enough to
eat
yeah i was watching uh we were watching
thank you gadgey3
because it's been a while late because
of football and beer still on it
thank you very much thank you very much
yeah hold on let me uh
let's see yes he goes to top chat
instead of live chat for some reason
that's [ __ ]
crazy why it does that we were remember
how i was telling you guys earlier
on another show that back in europe and
the honky motherland
they showed wood cuts of big piles of
corn
and apples and food and next to it would
be a cow
and the cow and the pile are about the
same size
and then next to that would be a catfish
and the catfish is the same size as the
cow
people always thought that that was they
were just doing that that it wasn't the
scale it was just i
see i don't think that's that crazy
because i've seen catfish almost that
big yeah
jeremy wade was saying no that was scale
we don't know how long
catfish actually live and in the modern
era people have [ __ ] rod and reel and
with rod and reel you can get catfish
when they're [ __ ]
still young but the medievals and even
even you know back in the 1700s people
didn't have rod and reel
so they caught fish with a net
and once a fish got too big to catch
with the net you could only catch the
small ones and the bigger ones would
just be out there getting bigger and
bigger they didn't know how long a
catfish can like
[ __ ] your net so for all you know a
catfish might get to be the size of a
cow
because those in that same areas in
those lakes they were afraid of getting
eaten by [ __ ] lake monsters
well what are they talking about it
doesn't go out to the sea
so it was some fresh water that was
eating them it might have been them
catfish
i don't doubt ridiculous well because
even nowadays
now that everything's been like [ __ ]
fish to death right and you would think
that like all the really big [ __ ] was
gone
jeremy wade on that show has shot some
catfish that were almost as big as a cow
yeah like and he pulled that [ __ ] out
and i was just kind of like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah they were
in brazil though yeah but there wasn't
anybody fishing them see
so a fish could get old they don't know
how old they are though
um well jeremy wade
did did talk about on that show the last
time he they caught a shark
it was a greenland shark and it was a
40 year old juvenile
a 40 year old juvenile how old is an
adult
they were saying that some of these
adults were 200 years old
well like i said that's not crazy
because they know that some tortoises
like some reptilian
stuff like that can live 200 years 200
year old adult
shark with all the vigor of a young
shark
and people are saying well you grow old
you die you get weak
no that's humans other species don't
they don't
growing old getting weak and dying is an
error
there are other [ __ ] it's a genetic
error there are other creatures that
grow old they grow old but they don't
get weak they just continue to get big
they get bigger and bigger and bigger
and they don't
have any signs of loss of vitality they
get more they get stronger
and they they do eventually die
evidently but it's probably because they
can't feed themselves they're so big
they can't get enough foods they slowly
start well yeah because once you get to
a certain size you need like a certain
amount of calories to maintain that size
and if you can't
find enough food but theoretically back
in the dinosaur era where everything got
big
they probably also everything lived a
long time how much you want to bet some
of those
dinosaurs and huge megalodon sharks that
they had
they may have been centuries old
they might have been like a mega those
gigantic megalodon shark might have been
500 years old for all you know
well like i said if there was enough
food there to sustain them because you
could keep them eating
because those [ __ ] were massive think
about it
if if a shark in the modern era can live
to 200
back in that old environment 500 [ __ ]
that ought to be reasonable
because the 200 year old ones that they
[ __ ] pull up have no signs of
dying of old age they're getting
stronger
yeah it's amazing when you think about
it
for all you know that [ __ ] might be
500 600 700 year olds the thing we're
coming at things from a very
human-centered
standpoint i mean humans you know upper
limit
of our lifespan is probably like 120
years old
um so we it blows our mind when we
hear about like you know galapagos
tortoises or something like that that
could live like 200 years at least
um or even like [ __ ] some trees that
can live like hundreds and hundreds of
years
so you know it's amazing but i guess
it's not really that amazing from their
standpoint because that's just like a
natural humans don't live long
because we don't live long you know what
i mean so
it's just kind of that that type of
thing but uh yeah one of the shows that
we saw last night too was
i think the one that we saw that was
like um a bunch of people that
they didn't know what happened to but
like a bunch of people kept disappearing
and then there was a whole thing about
um
i think this was in mexico and they were
talking about how there weren't really
that many
sharks around anymore because a lot of
them had been illegally fished
and then like another predator had moved
into their niche right
and so then like all the old fishermen
were saying yeah they kept calling it
like the red devil
right and so jeremy wade does his little
investigation and he found out that it
was actually a
massive school of humble squid which are
red
normally although they can change color
and uh
apparently allegedly they were grabbing
people and like
[ __ ] eating them you know and he went
and he went to
um somewhere off like south america or
something because the the
the pack or whatever you call a bunch of
humble squid i'm not really sure
uh a pod maybe that's whales but he went
like a long way
and then like they had moved on to
another location
and he went out on a boat and he's like
i couldn't
not catch humble squid he kept like
catching he caught like a zillion of
them they were
around a school of 1000. yeah there was
like a huge huge school of them and he
just kept bringing them up into the boat
they weren't big
but he's like you know if you fell into
the water right now be eating a lot
they'd probably just [ __ ]
they eat each other when they get mad um
fourth door down says many species get
cancer as they get older yeah that's
because there's errors there's genetic
errors in their genome
well that's kind of what cancer is right
it's just an error
but things like sharks don't have those
errors evidently
they've been around for too long or have
them fewer for like
it's just fewer i guess that's an
ancient species any problems would have
been long since
ironed out i'm sure yeah you think same
thing with a horseshoe crab
they're damn near and destructible and
almost like something from another
planet
which theoretically if you
can do gene editing you could take a
human genome and maybe perfect it
get rid of all the [ __ ] problems and
all the junk dna
and make and once you did that
maybe maybe be feasible to have a five
or six hundred year old human being
with no real size sign of well i'm
pretty sure that that's coming
yeah i mean because genetic engineering
i mean yeah it's kind of in its infancy
but
i i think it's gonna go that way yeah
it has to because
for some people the normal human
lifespan is not long enough
i'm 53 and it doesn't feel like it's
long enough i could do
that i got [ __ ] i got to do yeah i could
deal with another hundred years no
problem
yeah i could do easily yeah i i could i
could keep uh
myself busy oh i totally go yeah and
what
what would be cool about having a
[ __ ]
your lifespan 200 year life span is that
you could take a decade off
and you're not and you wouldn't feel bad
[Music]
[ __ ] it i'ma rest for 10 years
yeah just sit around work out and eat
look at porn for about 10 minutes
then i'm gonna [ __ ] jump back and
then i'll go back to go back into the
world well i think that's the [ __ ]
vampires well yeah that's the shittiest
thing about how short our lifespans are
and this is something i think about a
lot like especially
especially since i've gotten a little
bit older is that
any like i feel like i can't take a
break or i'm
like wasting time you know what i mean
and it's it's shitty because i shouldn't
feel like that i should be able to relax
but i can't
victor garcia sent a 10 thank you victor
sent a five dollar chat saying i got my
owl shirts badass i think he's talking
about
the the tyrell tyrell corporation more
human than human shirt
yeah did i mention did i mention earlier
that uh
no need for me too wanted a cat shirt oh
i'll get him one
oh yeah yeah yeah we have to make one i
think i told it to you before we started
streaming but i don't think i set it on
yeah i don't know it's gonna be the size
of a cat
yes he wanted a shirt for his cat carpet
okay and i was just kind of like we
could work them out i was like well [ __ ]
yeah
yeah we can make that i was like while
i'm doing that i might make one for
pookie too i don't know if she'll wear
it though
she probably won't shook it all there's
another shirt that we're selling right
here
this is the one of the new 13 o'clock
podcast shirt it's got
it's got jenny and me and it's got
pookie in beijing and it's made like a
ouija board yeah that's my favorite if
you're interested in a shirt like this
you can drop us twenty dollars in the
super chat for a limited time right now
drop
twenty dollars into super chat and later
on we'll hook it up i'll send you one of
your
of yours well i mean i need you like
your size and your you need your size
yeah
contact you there but yeah i just said i
sent one to australia yesterday
so um gadgey3 says 53 you look better
than i do
well like i said i'm using technology
and i'm using
knowledge and training what we know now
is a lot more than what we knew back
even 10 years ago i just said [ __ ] man i
remember looking at my parents yearbooks
thank you victor give me the ouija shirt
okay all right all right what size you
want yeah just tell me what size
i think i've sent i think i think we
might have victor's
address already don't we yeah i think i
do but just in case
i'm pretty sure i did yeah contact us
just in case yeah um
any more of that there we've got 20 for
a shirt i'll send you 20
first year 29 for sure uh what i was
saying is uh
the knowledge is out there but
general practic practitioner doctors
say like for y'all peasants they're not
into that [ __ ] and they don't know much
about it well no one loves peasants
nobody loves you peasants
rich people have access to access to all
kinds of weird [ __ ] that they don't talk
about because their friends are doctors
they don't go to hospitals they go to
their [ __ ] compounds and work on them
doing weird [ __ ] like blood transfusions
with younger kids young kids that have
[ __ ]
um hormonal [ __ ] processes going on
in the body so it's kind of like hrt
form um
evidently like the blood of teenagers
transfused into the body helps reprogram
the [ __ ] blood marrow
your bone marrow who knows
who knows but these are rich people with
access to a lot of technology
that are getting into all that also
they're all doing hrt they're all on
hormone replacement
because they don't make enough hormones
to stay healthy so they inject them
into themselves which makes a big
difference i've been there i'm doing
that now
it repeals decades right back off you
you're like that damn lizard or that
alligator that's 150 years old you
continue growing into
shrinking and you guys have seen the
difference in me [ __ ] the past
90 days that i've been on that i worked
out for two years and i got
lifted and i got good progress but it
started to stall out it was too hard to
maintain it was con
never really could recover or heal up
felt like [ __ ]
grumbling in my sleep a lot fighting it
constantly
go on hrt and solved all that dumb
problem the only problem it didn't solve
is that i keep attacking jenny she's
running from me she's sick
too much dick too much
too much dick she's not into it the uh
[Laughter]
but no uh it's not that i'm not into it
it's just sometimes i'm in the middle of
it
i understand i understand you don't
understand the power power of the
[ __ ]
no i get it it's i get it yeah the white
snake
well you know that's that's what i was
like when i was young yes like that
see well not quite that bad um
you hang on pretty well no matter if
you're male or female mostly you
but around 35 if you're a male
testosterone production starts to
decline
it's just part of your genome your your
your you're built that way
so after 35 it starts to decline
and a lot of the your secondary sex
characteristics start to fade
and just starts to get to where you get
fat you can't get weight off you
you work out you can't build muscle and
you can't burn fat either
and then your vitality starts slipping
away
uh you hit 50 and all of a sudden a lot
for a lot of guys it hits rock bottom
depression comes in that's when a lot of
guys are retiring from their work and
traditionally they retire from their
work and were dead two years later
because they drank themselves death or
committed suicide well and because their
work was their entire identity right
but it was also linked up with basically
[ __ ]
that's kind of like kind of like
andrenopos
male andrenopos it's kind of like the
male version of menopause
uh some dudes make it beyond that and
can live to be old men of course
but some dudes don't the higher
intensity
you're more your addiction to [ __ ]
high intensity stuff
if you're a cop military firefighter
construction worker anybody who
lived a dangerous life adrenopause hits
you a lot of those guys [ __ ] die
well it hits you a lot harder because
it's a larger transition it's a larger
transition i mean
that's kind of the thing it's like if
you and i think that
happens why you see why you used to see
you don't really see it that much
nowadays
but you used to see particularly the
boomer era he would see dudes
and they had worked for 30 years 40
years in the same uh
field and then they would retire and a
year or two later they'd be dead
and i think that was because one their
entire they ran them hard
yeah one yeah they ran them hard and
they just like [ __ ] they didn't do
that anymore so they couldn't really
think of anything else to do
and that was kind of like their entire
identity so they felt like they didn't
really have anything to live for anymore
well i think it's hormonal too they ran
out really hard and they were addicted
to running really hard yeah as soon as
that was gone they're like
what am i here for right then there's a
hormonal crash and they died
and the thing about it too is that a lot
of them you know now they're suddenly
home
all day yeah and their wives are kind of
like you're just
in my way i'm trying to do the [ __ ] that
i'm normally doing around the house and
you're just like
like a lump sitting there and it's just
kind of like so they kind of felt like
even more useless i guess
so there was that whole uh issue as well
like i said that was mostly a
thing i think but hey with modern
technology the medical knowledge
uh [ __ ] youtube and everything and
veterans and everybody
veterans the military police [ __ ] uh
any high any high action even your
athletes and stuff
they all know now because because of
youtube we can all talk to each other
these dudes that come out of special
forces and delta
the first thing they do is go on hrt as
soon as they retire
because everybody knows now a lot of
these guys that
get diagnosed with ptsd they start
shooting them up a [ __ ] test
and the ptsd symptoms go away which i
had that a lot of
my symptoms of ptsd went away because it
means
well you had that bad like especially
when i first met you yeah
and it's because you immediately go back
into a mental positivity
not negativity but positivity it's a big
difference
and it's because your hormones are
[ __ ] with you you see here's the deal
men bent bent over backwards for decades
to try to figure out female hormones to
prevent
pregnancy with that god damn pill but
they didn't give a single [ __ ] about the
male horn endocrine system and male
hormones
males also had a hormonal artery well no
they were trying to they were trying to
work on a male uh birth control pill
yeah but that would [ __ ] you but i felt
like it didn't really go that
way anywhere because a lot of dudes
didn't want to take it because they're
like oh it'll [ __ ] up my hormones and
i'm like hello
it's been [ __ ] up our hormones for
like [ __ ] however long we've had the
pills
yeah but what it would do to man it
would [ __ ] either increase the
increase your testosterone to the point
where it would shut
shut your nuts down and they would
atrophy and it would make you more
aggressive
or it would decrease your testosterone
to make you a fat butter ball and sit
around do nothing
so you you got to do something you got a
mon
a male want to be happy he must be have
vitality and positivity and when he's in
that range he's growing
and he's fertile okay you're emulating
fertility of your prime years
you're doing it artificially by
exogenous testosterones in other words
exogenous hormones
you're taking hormones from outside the
body and you're putting them in there
to to replicate the prime of life
that's what they're doing well the prime
of life for males he's fertile
so you can't get off that i mean you
know
women they shouldn't be doing it if you
ask me what i know about the female
endocrine system now
the birth control pill should really
shouldn't exist i mean i've known
like pretty much everybody is on that
right um
and when i was younger i took
birth control pills with really no side
effects
but when i got older and i got switched
to a different brand
um yeah i did not enjoy that experience
there shouldn't be birth control pills
and you know
how that [ __ ] went but like it doesn't
affect everybody the same way though
because like i said for 20 30 years i
took them with no [ __ ] problem at all
i didn't have any size
or anything it depends on which birth
control pill there it is
if it's one that's to elevate estrogen
which an estrogen imbalance
what tends to happen what tends to
happen eventually
in the long run is that you gain weight
you get crazy makes you fat and crazy
that's what that's what that's what they
do not everybody but like it's with the
tendency
yeah it's fat and crazy really the
safest form of birth control is condoms
that's what really you know we have
birth control they shouldn't be [ __ ]
with women's education systems i don't
think it's right
it's not right in the long term but it's
just like anything else it's their
bodies and they yeah
and like i said it's not good for you
when i was young yeah uh
i didn't have any side effects i didn't
have any bad side effects so i took them
for 20 30 years and i didn't have any
problem
it was only when i got older and it got
switched to a different
type of pill well you don't know that
there were no side effects because you
don't see
another example of what what you would
have been like or looked like without it
well i mean i didn't feel any different
like nobody complained about me being
like
[ __ ] crazy or anything you might have
had without birth control pill
less tendency to [ __ ] in other words
you'd probably had a greater tendency to
to [ __ ] keep a lean body mass with
the equivalent with the same diet
yeah but i don't think so though because
every single female on my mom's side of
the family is built exactly like me but
were they
taking birth control pills no you don't
know that you know
or you know that are you doing well i
know i know for a fact that some of them
were not
okay um that's just what our body type
looks like
every single woman on my mom's side of
the family is built pretty much exactly
the thing that another thing that's
happened is that there's a difference
between
a woman who is
fertile and one that's post-menopausal
post-menopause there's a bunch of [ __ ]
that's possible also
with with hrt age extension or
life extension
i i think i would talk to i think i
mentioned it to you
before but there are some people
that are some women that after menopause
take small
doses of testosterone that convert into
estrogen
and with good effect
and there's been some studies that talk
about it from harvard university
that it prevents a lot a lot of problems
like osteoporosis
obesity uh [ __ ] uh lack of energy
um [ __ ] weight gain there's a lot of
stuff to it
hormones are the key those are the
signals that keep your body running
and keep things working right and
there's errors in the human body
the hormonal production should not be
decreasing
it doesn't decrease in more primitive
animals like these dams sharks
and these turtles their shit's about the
same
it decreases in us just because that was
the hand we were dealt through evolution
now some might say well having to having
hormonal
values inside your bloodstream for that
amount of time
long term might be bad it still wouldn't
matter
you'll you'd die anyway okay
it would be worth it to die five years
early
but to [ __ ] be healthy in those in
that final 50 years
you don't talk about well like i said
everything's a trade-off
it's kind of yeah and it's kind of the
thing where
you don't you don't know you don't
really know what age you would have done
had you not intervened right in anything
so it's kind of like oh i died when i
was like you know
70 or whatever but it's like you might
have died earlier you might have
died later you don't really know the
only thing you can do is go by human
experimentation from the past and most
of the human
experimentation in this country was
illegal because it was people messing
with
anabolic steroids most of them at this
point were men
some men abused anabolic steroids and
died early
other ones used it at light therapeutic
doses
doses and seem to have good results
which would be like jackal lane
jacqueline used anabolics but he was
very light with it
he lived into it i believe his late 80s
and he did die
but he died in his late 80s but he died
strong and in good condition
because steroids kind of looks like
testosterone it's
kind of like testosterone replacement
um it's more targeted to muscle
i think i'd really use testosterone
instead of steroids but i think he used
i think he used [ __ ] like anabar
this is kind of hard on your liver but
he lived he lived
i think it was 80 something years old
well and like i said a lot of times
it's hard to say because a lot of
people's uh you know everybody's
genetics are different
because i you know everybody has stories
of
you know somebody that died that was
real healthy and died real young
like my uncle did he died when he was
32. yeah so we might a built-in brain
tumor
yeah um and some people know people like
drink and smoke their whole life
and they like live till they were like
[ __ ] 95.
yeah so genetics obviously has a
component very much there's a component
there like yeah your lifestyle matters
right i don't know and this goes to
you know if you're in the fitness scene
in the bodybuilding scene
once you understand what what you know
these hormones these compounds that
they're taking
they all work out they all take that
stuff but they're really the thing that
puts them over the edge was
what their genetics were like in other
words what the skeleton was already
shaped like to begin with
and what and how genetically they
responded to those drugs
some people [ __ ] respond some people
don't respond that well
some people super respond some people
hyper respond
to that [ __ ] where he takes x amount
and instead of getting x results he gets
four times the results
on that same amount because his
particular [ __ ] genome for some
reason or another
is just real good at dealing with
responding to that [ __ ] hormone or
steroid
and with seemingly no ill effect and
then there might be another person
that'll take that same amount and it
they might just not tolerate it very
well you know i mean my whole thing
like i said my body type is very much
dictated by
my mom's side of the family all of the
females on my mom's side of the family
look
are pretty much built exactly like me
little bitty short legs little bit of
short arms
kind of chunky that's just kind of like
what they all look like
another thing that is pretty endemic to
that side of the family which i'm pretty
sure i inherited
is that drugs of any sort
have almost no effect
but also on the flip side of that um i
also don't
hardly ever get sick from anything um
anything that's you know chicken pox
anything like that as a kid
um i would get it it would be super
super minor
um so i get that like i get a cold or a
flu it'd be super super minor or i
wouldn't even
get it and that it's been like that so
since i can remember since i was a
little bit again
but conversely when i've taken
medication
um also doesn't do [ __ ] yeah
it also it doesn't do no need for me too
just showed up hey
what's up somebody was saying uh that
their mom took
i think post-menopausal [ __ ] hormones
for years
but and then he still saw her calendar
hanging up whatever that was all about
well yeah you have to like yeah i don't
know i don't have the context
but that well that's the thing i always
kind of felt like
because i just how long ago was it i had
i went through menopause i'm 48. i'll be
49 this year
um i'm pretty sure my mom went through
menopause about the same age maybe she
was in her early 50s
but i kind of feel like a lot of people
told me oh it's this big [ __ ] thing
oh it's good
for someone it's gonna suck so bad and
yeah i'm sure it is for you she ran into
tina
yeah and she and it was really bad for
her and like i know it is for a lot of
it but for me it was just kind of like
yeah wait that was it it was just i had
like a few hot flashes
for like a few weeks and i was like oh
it's kind of hot in here and then that
was about it
it might have been it was like oh that
was it all right
the thing is though is you know you
probably would have
some women some women are running off of
it off of a fair every woman runs on
on their own the hormonal [ __ ]
plateau you know you might not have been
all that hormonal did you have real bad
acne when you were a kid
no then that's probably part of it no i
always had lovely clear
skin my friends were always like so so
jealous
like i would get a zit every now and
then yeah but even
like all through my teenage years i had
lovely clear skin you may have not have
been super hormonal to begin with so the
the
lack of it really wasn't that much of a
shock well i feel like i was in the
sense that
you know i was real uh you know i i was
real like horny all the time
yeah that doesn't really mean much but
right but other than that
i was like pretty chill yeah um i didn't
have all this kind of like oh i'm so
like emotional or whatever
i was pretty like level yeah i think i
think that's probably what it is and
maybe that's why i like
because my levels were always like kind
of
super hormonal women are [ __ ] usually
nuts
sexy but nuts
[Laughter]
emotionally volatile um see i've never
had that i'm pretty chill right yeah
and yeah like i said it's just you're
like [ __ ] dating a dude
you're just reasonable and i'm not used
to a woman being reasonable
you can basically reason with her dudes
you guys in the comments section you can
comment are you able to reason with a
[ __ ] woman no
no usually you're not well see that's
well that kind of [ __ ] makes me mad
though because
no they use women are not reasonable
they no
they are everybody i knew like they
weren't like well i don't hang out with
like [ __ ]
crazy ass you don't hang out with crazy
women okay look you don't hang out with
normies
i hang out with normal well people that
are normal to me they're normal to you
because they're just normal
they're from our scene and they're not
they're not normal
normal would have been like
the girls that before we were going out
the ones that i would go out there you
hated
they were like that's the normal one
we're not going to say what her name is
but i know who you're talking yeah
yeah you know how when you go okay you
know when we go to mannequins
that girl was in that case you know when
you know when we go to mannequins
and [ __ ] all the normies come out and
dancing in a circle with their purses in
the middle and [ __ ]
that's normal that's normal girls that's
so that sounds
that makes me so sad that's them yeah
that makes sense yes
and if you talk to them your [ __ ]
world will be turned upside down because
it doesn't make a bit of fun
see this is why i'm really really glad
that i'm in the goth scene because
pretty much everybody well other than
like a couple of exceptions
pretty much everybody in the godsend man
or a woman is pretty [ __ ] reasonable
thank you no need for me too 1999.
need to get a few more shirts left a
message on patreon for sizes and who
yeah
um i saw that message you want us to
make a message
a t-shirt for the kitty i can do that
yeah we can do that you can do that we
can do that no problem we've got to find
a source for those little bitty shirts
but leaky shoes i'm pretty sure jiffy
shirts has that
they have everything else like i said
i'm i'm gonna make one we'll make a cat
shirt
for pook and everybody else and then
we'll make it i don't know we'll make it
you'll get the first one because she'll
just be like what are you doing to me
why you'll get the first one and uh
we'll come up with a good 13 o'clock
kitty
i'm so glad that carpet came out of the
surgery yeah like i was like really
bummed about it and
so far cats so far this laptop is
kicking ass
there hasn't even been a single hiccup i
love it
i mean thank you very much thank you
very much
i mean that one i bought a little while
back was
all right but grandpa says do god women
have
first of all just can't speak to goth
women as if they're like a damn race
they're just like a group
um well you can't speak of women
everybody's different
do they have depressive tendencies more
than mundane um
maybe you know what i don't know though
i don't know though i don't think so
there's a certain element that
come and go very quickly that i would
say might
um but no like the long-term ones no
they're cool
they're very cool you just takes time to
get to know them and you have to be one
of them
it's like i said it's it's it's like a
cult or a mafia
it's a subculture it's like its own
country
well and the thing is you can't just
approach them as kind of like
i don't know it's hard to say because i
feel like this is why i've always hung
out with
i mean i've hung out with gods my whole
life and
just because you know that's what i'm
into
and that's the kind of people that i'm
attracted to
so i don't know how it works with
regular people
because regular people are just like
mystifying to me
but like i see them at mannequins and
i'm just like
it's like an alien all right graham it's
an alien species yeah graham
mary lynn would have made a good goth
she was a goth in a way
she's like a proto-goth she didn't make
a very good goth
um who else would have been a good guy
um
that you would have known
carrie you know [ __ ]
steve's ex-girlfriend remember carrie
she would have made a good goth
in her youth i think she went she got
into alcoholism though and [ __ ]
herself up
um see i don't think though i think
there's a perception
um you know from kind of the mainstream
world whatever you want to call it
that goths are more prone to depression
or mental health issues and i don't
think that's the case
yeah graham remember jeans the case
remember my ex girl remember my little
ex-girlfriend jean
she was she was a little punk rock girl
she'd have made a real good goth she's
not goth anymore though
i'll show you gene in case gene
petrowski remember i got
i got a picture of jean from back in the
day that i bet you you haven't seen
you haven't seen this gene in [ __ ]
damn 30-something years hold on
let me show you i will say that i think
that perception maybe comes from the
fact that
the god scene is more open to
what i
remember come on i remember you showing
that picture
yeah remember the light there yeah
remember gene that was uh
1986 87 yeah
i think the thing is that in the goss
scene people are more
they seem to be more open and they seem
to be more open to talking about those
type of mental health issues so maybe
there's a misperception
that that it's more prevalent you know
what i mean just because they're more
they're more apt to talk about it than
maybe like normal people would i don't
know if that's the case anymore but it
used to be back in the old days
i never felt that because you know i
hung out with like gossip punks and
stuff i knew some like normal ass people
too
but i didn't really see that much
difference
in mental health issues between those
two groups
i just feel like you know goths are more
open to talking about it and they're
more open about it
so maybe that's what it is i don't know
yeah grant
says he remembers her yeah gene
patrowski
scott says normies talk to therapists
goths talk to each other yeah maybe
that's what it is
yeah maybe that's what it is i mean
because i do kind of feel like i mean
you guys know i get drunk
particularly i get drunk on this show
and like i'll just talk about [ __ ]
anything i don't care
but i think there's still maybe among
more more normal people maybe there's a
thing where they don't want to like talk
about stuff
to like a wider audience
there's also generational differences
that too
okay like [ __ ] goths of all different
ages will be hanging out in the club
some of them are parents
to the kids which is a weird thing that
would never happen with our generation
but goth people our age that have kids
their kids are in the clubs
and there isn't a big generational gap
or divide not really
not that much okay not really um
their kids are on the same kind of [ __ ]
yeah i'd be mortified as hell if i can
go to club my mom be there but no
they're [ __ ] girls in there [ __ ]
hanging out with their mom and this and
that chasing dudes and [ __ ] it's just
it's like a tribal type situation and
it's
they're all jabbing to the same music
and [ __ ] it's not really it's
not normal it's not normal from our
point of view it's the new normal
uh it's better i like it it's a lot
better i like it
because i kind of feel like it's
unhealthy right the generation
gaps were not and like my parents like
your parents were not cool but like my
parents
were were okay like my dad was super
into like music and he got me out of
music when i was young
my mom is super cool i would not be
averse
to bringing my mom to a club i don't
think she'd want to
but you know my mom yeah yeah right she
wouldn't be into any of that though
no she's not really into that but she
wouldn't like be weird or obnoxious or
anything because she's like really sweet
and really cool
but you know my dad was like super into
music and he'd probably be like all
right with it
but you know i can sit like a lot of
people that grew up in our generation
like generation x like your parents were
lame
yeah you didn't want your parents like
that was like super embarrassing
there were certain generations and the
boomers were kind of one of them
they really got off on riding wrongs and
setting people straight and fixing
things
so if they saw something that wasn't
what they would consider to be right
they would try to
condemn it or something oh that's not
good
like an x generation and below doesn't
really give a [ __ ] if something isn't
good they're like well i'm just like hey
is that working for you
all right whatever you do whatever yeah
did whatever
boomers were more like the japanese the
japanese were like that
well it's like japanese divine i'm
really really glad that that
mindset is going away because i really
don't like oh this is the way we do
things and then
there's we can brook no opposition right
yeah
um i don't like that yeah when the
japanese looked at it like to be
different
is to attack harmony and only a bad
person would attack harmony
you have to go or be corrected
the japanese are extremely conformist
starting at school
and the americans were never usually not
really that bad
but they had those tendencies
it was in japan guys
and creating systems that constantly
told other people what they couldn't do
you can't do this you can't do that you
don't see anything about it today
you kind of brought it to the front
forefront of my mind i was like yeah
the boomers kind of had that but not as
bad as the japanese
but it's still there you can't take them
to a club they'll go oh this is wrong
this is terrible this is a little
affects society in a bad way
and they have no idea what they're
talking about because they don't
understand the culture
at all nothing really happening at a
goth club that threatens
cult society no of course not as long as
they're old enough they're just like
hanging out they're listening to music
they're having a drink
it's the same [ __ ] that's been going on
since the 1700s sure it's just
done in a slightly different way in the
1700s they would have called it a
hellfire club
that's what they would have called a
hellfire club and benjamin franklin went
to him
to be honest with you goth clubs are and
i've heard this from cops as well
are far far less trouble yeah than
mainstream normal
yeah no law enforcement don't give a
[ __ ] you don't really see a lot of
fights or anything like that
every now and then you do but not it's
obituary though
[ __ ] fighting it's over some [ __ ] that
somebody said
some girl this and that dj maniac says
when i was 18 my mother showed up at my
club while i was fooling around with a
girl
see oh my god holy crap that's not the
same for me because i'm a girl but you
know
brian says tom what is your dad's
perception of the goth culture
oh he just thinks it's crazy crazy
man that's crazy you gonna wear them
pants
and pants are shiny them shiny black
pants
[Laughter]
damn you gonna get beat up dressed like
that you know
they just they just don't understand
this [ __ ] to them it's still
[ __ ] 19 not even the 1960s my dad's
from mississippi so it's still like
1955.
i said dad you know what i could talk
about man i don't know man i don't know
them girls are kind of crazy yeah
he didn't like that [ __ ] which is weird
because like i said
i don't know maybe it's just like my
perception and like you said i'm a
weirdo i guess i
i guess i own that but um
to me like it's always seemed like
pretty normal like and
it's not all that weird nobody's doing
anything crazy nobody
well they did take aurora stick hooks in
her back and suspended for
right but that's not that weird they're
not like it's not like they're made
there we're not sacrificing babies
nobody's doing anything they don't want
to do
pain acrobats and [ __ ] maybe i'm jaded
that's not weird
we kind of are that's not weird
yeah like i said nobody's making you do
that they're just kind of like hey
this is like a thing that we do and we
like get into and we're
off on it get off on it and i'm just
like okay no we're a little bit
we're not seeing it through the eyes of
maybe not of them
well i don't know like like i said maybe
maybe i'm jaded i'm old i'm a horror
writer
yeah you know i've been in this scene a
long time let me show you what what i'm
talking about
yeah this is what's going on at
mannequins that's aurora hung from her
back by hooks and we're swinging her
around and everybody's
yay it's he like to me that's not that
weird i saw her do that like years and
years ago
yeah nobody thinks that's weird
everybody's just like yeah cool
it's just old-fashioned [ __ ] now yeah
yeah
that's aurora van
that was just uh that wasn't that long
that was just like a couple weeks ago a
couple weeks ago
maybe a month ago
yeah maybe that was out back on the
patio yeah she did that before
like uh the grotto yeah we did that big
show when she was married to uh
jacob she's with that new act they
actually do that [ __ ] for the [ __ ]
sturges and all the bike week and uh
doing it on stage
yeah so that's with them yeah i wasn't
that long ago that was just a few weeks
ago we saw that
but yeah she's done that before and it's
like i don't know like to me it just
seems like
there's a lot of normies that would be
like what the [ __ ] is that all about
even nowadays
i kind of feel like we've gotten past
that point like everybody's seen
everything
you got like everybody should be well i
got you
i got past that point 30 years ago i
don't know why everyone's taking yeah
you got fast so i just kind of like
thought everybody would like
be into that [ __ ] by now and just be
like man whatever yeah if you want to do
that you can do that it's not like by
it's not bothering anybody
you're not bothering anybody no one
underage is in there
no one said who think of the children
you two said i just saw serpent the
rainbow last night it's pretty good
movie you like it
that's pretty good i love that movie
there's just some i don't know there's
like some vibe about that that i really
like
i read the book too but it was a long
time ago book's non-fiction
so the movie is like a little bit of a
fictionalization but you know yeah seth
says
isn't suspension just viewed as a form
of body art see that's what i thought
just kind of like [ __ ] man when i got my
first tattoo
whenever that was late 80s early 90s
whatever it was
um the dude that gave me the tattoo and
it wasn't massive but it was on my arm
it was an owl it's been covered up since
then he was like a biker
because it was in daytona and he said
are you sure you want this tattoo on
your arm
because people think things about girls
that have tattoos on their arms
and this was i think early 90s
that's ridiculous he wanted to put it
somewhere that would be easy
to cover yeah right yeah like on the
back of my leg or something like that
and i was like dude
what the yeah i was like no put it on my
[ __ ] arm like i'm paying you to do
now that same night she was swinging
this is that same girl all right
and she's she's gonna be pushing 40 now
huh
she gotta be probably she's quite a bit
younger than us but she's gonna be 40
something
and she's got at least two kids all
right
and she's just
oh it's just kind of normal [ __ ] to us
but that's who that was swinging
[Laughter]
[ __ ] aurora yeah
that's that was jenny there by the door
that's out front of mannequin yeah
that's out in front of mannequins
was that the night i was dressed like
bride of franken's night yeah it was
that was halfway at home right halfway
to halloween
but yeah i don't know i just i
i guess we kind of got like ahead of the
[ __ ] maybe yeah we had a big head start
all our generation did there's still
just so many people that don't know what
that is
and like if you think that that's very
strange
well what's weird to me is that
sometimes
you don't see it so much at ibarr but at
mannequins
which is downtown sanford and you get a
lot of like kind of
just people that wander in from the
other bars or restaurants like in
downtown sanford and sanford is like a
lot smaller than
it's right outside of orlando but it's a
lot smaller
and you sometimes still get people in
there that are like
probably young enough to be our children
yeah
that are kind of like and they don't
really know what's going on like they
think it's weird still and like that is
super bizarre to me but what's what's
funny is that like the [ __ ] warlocks
motorcycle club i just instantly knew
what that was
like oh yeah yeah okay great oh this is
great isn't that funny
they knew all about subcultures
well i grew up around bikers so i know
yeah like i said i'm from daytona
yeah they don't have to leave but so
bikers were kind of like
we always had bikers there i don't know
it it's just like a weird thing so
it's it's not weird that like bikers
don't like norm but michael's bikers
just don't like normies
yeah they're like yeah yeah well like i
said you remember for a time when we had
venue 13 and we had it at that
kind of bikery bar and like half the bar
would be like
goth industrial people and like half the
barbie bikers we never had any trouble
yeah like and like i said i grew up in
daytona beach our big things
are bikers and spring breakers
yeah who would i rather hang out with
the bikers because the bikers don't
bother you
the spring breakers are [ __ ] because
they're all like
frat boys and [ __ ] like that and you
know how that check goes
i still don't like frat boys and a lot
of them like they kind of show up at the
bar and they're like they're the ones
that cause all the trouble
yeah no need for me says sexy i spent
under 200
i don't know what you're talking about
dude there's no context there
well it might have been like from earth
yeah okay it might have been about
uh aurora esther says she looks amazing
she's probably talking about [ __ ]
aurora
yeah rory's cute she's been around
forever
yeah we've known her you've known her
[ __ ] forever like i said her
ex-husband did this tattoo
yeah grandpa says how does her skin not
rupture she's not exactly a pixie
no she's she's kind of she's kind of
muscular actually
it doesn't go under her skin man it's
going through her [ __ ] her her
muscles
yeah yeah yeah so there's
she's just it's being supported by me
yeah me it's the same still
yeah it's the same [ __ ] same [ __ ]
[ __ ] um native americans would do you
know where they were hanging people from
the [ __ ] tops of the lodge poles like
out a
damn man called horse you know kind of
just a test of bravery
but the the the uh
the secret to it though is that it gets
numb so they don't feel it really once
it goes through there and it's just
they start pulling on it before they
even suspend them
but it's numb but still it's
they're paying acrobats you know i
wouldn't do it
but they'll do it through the backs and
then through the tops of the [ __ ]
legs through the knees they'll be
suspended in different points and
[ __ ] taking things up and splitting
them upside down
then she'll [ __ ] one time they had
her spinning by her back and she put her
little daughter out there
as a little girl you know and she
[ __ ] swings by and grabs her daughter
and she's [ __ ] hold her daughter
swinging through the air
but add more weight to it
got a pretty good crowd going got 40 in
there got 40 in here listening
so um what do you guys want to talk
about i can't sit here and just come up
with all these damn
all these damn conversations about
[ __ ] martial arts and [ __ ]
in checks from [ __ ] hooks and [ __ ]
you know i can't talk about that all day
just
looks like my uh hold up
oh that's what it is my chat was kind of
shut down see what's going on
yeah i had damn top chats on instead of
esther says tom i'm a normie i've seen
it hurt everything i'm very
jaded okay that's good then you're not
an army
i mean yeah like i said it's maybe jaded
is
looking out i'm trying to like vote no
need for me to says love that
yeah man she we got into a fight me
jenny and sonya over [ __ ] aurora's
ass one of these remember that when we
got in the fight with
over oh yeah that was a wild yeah
[ __ ]
she was jealous because
[ __ ] tanya is [ __ ] skinny
yes i'm [ __ ] drunk sonja's [ __ ]
skinny
okay she had big boobs and she was
skinny
yeah she weighed like maybe 90 pounds
yeah little bitty skinny thing
big implant center she looked like a
like a [ __ ]
old-school 80s pin book like
and we're talking about like on on a uh
uh [ __ ] cher bono level but she's
like she can do cher
[ __ ] perfectly all right because she
looks she looked like that
okay and she was going on about aurora's
fat ass and i went
this is sonny what are you talking about
got a [ __ ] nice ass when he took him
what are you talking about
her ass is not fast but yeah what are
you talking about she has a nice ass she
was just [ __ ]
hating her little skinniness was [ __ ]
hating on that ass i don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
[ __ ] her ass is me and jenny were just
laughing okay
okay sonya
[Laughter]
well we were we're pretty like hip to
her games yeah i know her games whatever
it was a good feature about you if you
were mad she'd attack
that's what that was that's a [ __ ] move
you know
and it's a really like transparent yeah
yeah everybody knew everybody knew her
[ __ ] game
because that was kind of her thing yeah
you know what i mean
yeah because she was real skinny yeah
which you know a lot of people like that
and a lot of people like you know liked
how she was built and stuff
but if you had like a little bit of a
bud or you know bigger boobs than her or
something like that
that was exactly what she would attack
and you knew exactly like why she was
doing that
because she was mad at you because she
didn't like you had a bigger broth than
her
yeah because she didn't have a butt
really
i remember i remember something that you
said about her although it's kind of
mean so i don't know if i want to say it
yeah you can say it yeah
that she looked the same from the back
as he did from the front
i think i said that to her too didn't it
i think he did yeah yeah yeah i think it
says
because i used to [ __ ] i used to
drive i used to drive her
see sonia used to pick on jenny a little
bit
but it was because sonia was nice to her
which is kind of a kind of a mistake
with sonia
you had to be cruel to her a little bit
and you had to be cool with her
but she also had to [ __ ] with her and uh
oh somebody sent us a super chat it'd be
good to pop out a bit yeah i'm like
yeah she she was addicted to like
abusive relationships if you were
thinking gadget3 what do you say shout
out to all who are struggling thanks tom
and jenny
thank you thank you seriously she was um
she was the kind of girl that liked
abusive relationships
for real if you were nice to her then
she thought something was up
yeah yeah if you were mean too which is
really sad yeah if you were mean to her
then you're a challenge
you know what i mean she was one of
those so
i was friends with her before i even
knew you yeah and
one of the reasons why i was friends
with her is because i was nice to her
but then when she would [ __ ] when she
would transgress
i'd [ __ ] hit her [ __ ] both give
her both barrels
and and that's how i earned respect
yeah yeah because you're an [ __ ]
that's an [ __ ] too
you know what i mean i'd be cool to her
and then if she came at me sideways i
just bam bam bam i'd hit her
not physically because it was something
that i said but yeah i'd say some [ __ ]
to her
that would [ __ ] her up you know what i
mean and then she'd come
come back okay okay okay you know
because she
that's how you earned respect she only
respected strength um
and style clothes had a lot to do with
it
but uh that was the thing you were
friendly to her
all the time you try to treat it like a
normal friendship
yeah and which get which she would
sometimes try to walk on you behind your
back
yeah i know and i'd call i'd call her
out on it oh i had many people call her
out i call her and tell me
about what she said about me behind my
mind yeah yeah yeah
and then she goes i was well aware well
and i call her on that [ __ ] and she go
well you know i just uh
you know and then she try to back off of
it we're just having fun you know
yeah yeah okay i got you [ __ ] yeah
frenemies
yeah she was the friend of me friend of
me tight [ __ ] yeah big time
but that was something that's the kind
of [ __ ] that i would say to her you know
it's just yeah you look [ __ ] great i
wish you had an ass though
you look like everything i wish you had
an ass though you look insane
from the front and the back if if you
didn't have them
if you didn't have those big ass titties
stuck in the front of you i wouldn't
know which side the [ __ ] [ __ ]
just say some crazy [ __ ] like that yeah
and she and she
oh well you started and then she'd come
right back she was an expert at it
she wouldn't take it that was kind of
her whole thing yeah yeah she's older
than we are
yeah she's old enough she's older than
you yeah yeah
you really wouldn't know but you
wouldn't no you wouldn't she has a kid
and everything
yeah i'll show i'll show a picture of
you guys but she would
she would [ __ ] if you were mean to
her and talk
crazy to her you'd you'd earn her
respect
yeah for some reason if you were nice to
her she didn't like that [ __ ] i don't
know i don't know what it was
sandra says is sonia the one who was on
the live show here with you with their
boyfriend in the horror baby
no that was uh shauna that was sean
sonia's never been
she's been to our house but she's never
been on the show we haven't seen her in
a while actually that was
that was sewn yeah yeah can't really
it's not really a good pitcher it's not
[ __ ] maybe i can find it there's a lot
of us
yeah because we used to take her we
should pick her ass up
yeah and take her to the club every week
for years and years
yeah me me jenny and sonia kind of that
was before i met
jenny actually that was sonia
yeah we kind of had a little thing going
on there for a little while
yeah we used to like uh
we used to pick her up and take her to
the club
because she would get super [ __ ] up
yeah and she was on again off again with
her boyfriend
slash baby daddy yeah who she's with
full time now
like they're raising the kid together
which that's good yeah
um we cut we kind of make out whether
yes so sometimes if everybody was drunk
if everybody
if there was like some vibes going on
but like i said it was kind of like a
thing where yeah
i don't know i never that's the shitty
thing
i never trusted her completely because i
knew she talked about me behind my back
yeah she did
she did not [ __ ] put my foot down on
that she's hey what the [ __ ]
because the weird thing about it is that
she didn't want to date you
no um but i just wanted to mess around
when someone else
was yeah she tried to stop that then she
would try to stop it because she wasn't
the center of attention yeah
right yeah so it was just kind of that
whole dynamic so i knew that that was
going on
because i knew that you didn't you i
mean you never dated her you never
you know we just messed around yeah so
it was just
that kind of thing and it's just kind of
like but she didn't want anybody else
having you either
yeah it was because she wasn't the
center of attention yeah this is some
weird [ __ ]
so it's like she'd always kind of have
to like intervene
yeah it was like a really weird it was a
really weird
situation yeah what do you think about
it
[Laughter]
it was just one of those things that
went down in the scene after a while
yeah it was yeah and then the baby daddy
was [ __ ]
looking at us like what the [ __ ] are you
doing with my [ __ ] baby mama
that weird [ __ ] is good like i said some
of the [ __ ] was going on when they were
broken up they were broken up
yeah so i'm not you know we didn't like
go behind his back or anything
he didn't like her going out ever yeah
yeah
he didn't want her going out ever which
like i said i can get that because she
would she'd go out she'd get super drunk
she got into some bad situations before
we started taking her i'm not gonna like
go into that
but she got into some bad situations
sandra who speaks giant flutely says ah
sonia is a threesome lady i wouldn't
really put it that way it's just you
know
[ __ ] happens sometimes you know it was
all between gods
it was got sexual
it's just [ __ ] that it was just [ __ ]
that sometimes happens
because uh that's the way it was that's
the way it was
well no one thinks too much about
thinking about i feel like a lot of
people that are into the gazing are kind
of just like whatever
okay yeah and normally it's like if
you're if your significant other is
there and then there's like another one
or another couple and you're just kind
of like well it's also
it's also kind of a different situation
in the
in the scene and especially between me
and me and her because we knew each
other before we were going out i knew
her when she was married
everybody knows everybody else before
any relationships go down
so everybody's already friends to begin
with yeah so the jealousy factor isn't
isn't really kind of
isn't really the same now if somebody's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't want that
around any girl you're with
you know what i mean but between all the
cool people
as i don't want to say it's like family
but it's kind of like family
that doesn't mean that the sex is incest
it's sex but it's just
it's not as personal or something it is
well it is like family yeah because the
thing about it is that
you have to think too and this isn't so
much the case with like the older people
but like the younger people that are in
the scene a lot of them you have to
think
um and we've known a couple people like
this that were like in their 20s or
whatever
um you know their parents like kicked
them out or they did you know
it's like why you look like this why are
you doing this and it's like you know so
they don't really have any place else to
go
so they come to the club and they meet
some people there
and it's kind of like they it's like
family but it's not yeah
so they found a family that they didn't
have yeah but it's not like you're
having sex with a family member that's
what it is yeah it's like
not like that yeah when we say it like
family yeah it's not weird
no no it's not weird it's just thank you
dean god damn i gotta come to florida
sometime
not enough for a drink this time maybe a
coffee love you guys for real
thank you well it's not just florida
it's the whole [ __ ] goth scene
yeah i kind of feel like everywhere you
go it's sort of similar
because well that's kind of the nice
thing about it that was one of the
things that i always liked about it was
that you know it's
big-ish especially in orlando and tampa
but
it's still small enough that you know
everybody or you know somebody that
knows
that person you know what i'm saying so
everybody is like your friend at one
remove
yeah everyone's dated everybody
nobody really has all that many secrets
from anybody no like everybody knows
every day
and everybody knows the deal everybody
knows so so when you meet a person
well i think that's kind of why too
we're so uh distrustful of
outsiders and strangers not to like a
horrible degree we're not like
super snotty or anything but when
somebody new comes in
everyone's very wary because it's like
man
we don't nobody knows you and it's like
you haven't been here for like i mean
i've lived here my whole life but it's
like
you know you've been here for what 10
years 11 years something like that
so everybody's been here for a really
long time and everybody knows each
other's business
um i mean it can get that [ __ ] can get
[ __ ] deep too
like i'm gonna give you an example
talking to some dude i'm not gonna name
any [ __ ] names talking to a dude that
i knew for years who was [ __ ] dating
a girl that i knew for years you know
who she is
[ __ ] i can show you pictures all
right okay
half brazilian girl
what was up with that is the last time i
saw him [ __ ] two weeks or two months
ago at [ __ ] momentous
so what was up with that he was dating
her so what was up with that chick and
he goes dude man
she was cool but man i had i had to stop
i had to stop [ __ ] [ __ ] with her
and i said
what was that she goes she kept trying
to peg me man
i said i ain't into that [ __ ] and i said
yeah good
i remember that conversation yeah i said
good man good man because i ain't gonna
i i ain't into that [ __ ]
you saw her man she's [ __ ] cute
really cute and the dude she's talking
about it's a [ __ ] latin [ __ ]
kind of a macho [ __ ] you know macho
[ __ ] latin goth dude you know
you guys are know she kept trying to peg
him and he's like [ __ ]
no fun you're talking about you know you
[ __ ] crazy you know he got sick of
that [ __ ] he's [ __ ] split
that's sick of that [ __ ] because this
[ __ ] wasn't normal man [ __ ] was adorable
too much too she too she too too bent on
it she too crazy with it i didn't know
man
i'm i'm not even making a comment yeah
that's one of you yeah she tries it
she well no that was a long time now i
ain't saying that
jenny got a jenny [ __ ]
i thought most of these [ __ ] women
are [ __ ] into that [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] crazy man they do that [ __ ]
thank you david june see you not giving
the money
what goes in grits gothic style squid
ink to make them black
no i'm just kidding gothic grits
dean says hey can i uh can i show off my
t-shirt
okay i'll get up this is my vampire
killing kit t-shirt
i got this at can you see it look at
those boobs guys look at those [ __ ]
booths
ripley's believe it or not museum yeah
yeah hold on hold on
they're not getting a good hold on wait
a second come on look at it look at this
see that right there all right all right
ten dollar super chat
this is what everybody like tunes in for
they're tuned in
yeah and uh i think grant there's hammer
asked if we had
we would be considered like the oh geez
wait wait wait wait
wait wait in here well we're we're among
them we're in them yeah because there's
a couple that's older than us
yeah but we're like in the top ten yeah
well we host club nights and [ __ ]
know all the dj's and [ __ ] do and
know the club owners and
do a lot of the [ __ ] i mean she does
all the
graphics if you walked out to some older
gods at some club and asked if they knew
who tom and jenny was yeah but you know
what i mean
[Laughter]
no need for me says uh pegging is not
for everyone some chicks are way too
aggressive
some chicks are way too aggressive with
the pegging they're trying to peg the
[ __ ] out of [ __ ]
and the straighter you are the more they
want to peg it because they're trying to
take your virginity
yeah and the [ __ ] man is going to be
going like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and then like
sandra who speaks jedi fluently german
gif
[Laughter]
tom is always i don't tell that [ __ ] and
then he tells the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah man well that's my style man that's
a style that's kind of what he does
maybe they don't have that storytelling
style in germany
but i suspect somewhere in germany
there's some [ __ ] like me
using that style probably he owes me
money
because you have a copyright i got a
copyright on issue scott asked does
visage still exist no visage is not
there anymore
um i remember it i went there back in
the day however
uh we do still have one of the main djs
from visage
paul vane who djs every i believe friday
and saturday at mannequins
so they're still around yeah it's still
around david june says the government
making sure we check out those boobs yes
indeed
camp guy says is pegging where they use
a strap on with extreme prejudice
something like that i think there's many
different variations on it you have to
[ __ ] confer with these perverted ass
[ __ ]
chicks man
we're not perverted yeah that's not
perverted they're not gonna try to come
at you with the [ __ ] broken broom
handle
some kind of big old black rub rubber
dick coming at you just some crazy [ __ ]
you know what i mean
that women have they have these
fantasies
oh and dudes don't
[Laughter]
women man's fantasies don't have
anything to do with violating a woman's
nature
yes yeah they do i don't think what are
you talking about
of course they do no man's ever gonna
try to put a mustache on you
make you dress like a man don't say that
because you know that there's like
at least a small group of people that
that's gonna try to put a mustache on
one
gonna make a woman into a man yeah you
can't say it's like oh no man's gonna do
it because there's
i guarantee you there's more than one
out there i guarantee
that is more than one person's fetish i
guarantee it sandra
get down here man with your [ __ ]
tube top and your flat chest and i'm
gonna put a mustache on you we're gonna
make a whole video about it
it's gonna be a fetish video series it's
called
it's called uh masculinating
sandra that's what it's called
gonna be hormone therapy and everything
yeah yeah when i'm done with you i'm
gonna make you a man
i don't think i would want to be a man
no doesn't really sound like that's fun
to be honest with you it's only good for
certain things
well not very many things now we talking
about let's see it's not right
no it's good to be a man
well i'm just saying like if somebody
asked me hey want to be a man tomorrow
yeah no thanks
well you're a woman it's no fun b it's
no film it's no fun being a woman tila
jumps in here what's up tina i'm not
saying that
but if i could choose i don't know it
just doesn't sound like that much fun
well life would be a lot simpler
probably
as a dude i kind of feel like that would
there a lot of problems
my problems would be solved but
i don't know there's something about it
just doesn't appeal to me
um let's see where was it uh scott says
wasn't an electric avenue before visage
i think it was yeah
uh oh lord is that what we're talking
about now
tom loves to talk about pegging you know
why
no we got on this subject because i
[ __ ] brought up
another another [ __ ] situation a
friend of ours a friend of ours
and her yeah i'm gonna go to the
restroom yeah and the girlfriend was
trying to get a drink when he come back
okay well here give me give me your
head when i come back i'll make you one
don't take it in the bathroom with you i
don't want to like all this [ __ ]
germs
i can't believe it's still [ __ ]
daylight out that's crazy
but yeah so yeah he brings up packing i
don't know he's into it secretly
gadget thank you gadget3 i remember tom
saying boobs he always has boobs
he's so boob fixated that's the only
thing
okay so that's the only thing that i
think
would make me i wouldn't mind being a
dude for like a day
just to see what it was like but
i don't know i kind of feel like i i
feel like your life would be a lot
simpler
because i don't know i kind of feel like
their their thought process is just like
boobs boobs boobs
ham sandwich all the time is that true
because i kind of feel like that's
what's going on
they don't have all this like
complicated
[ __ ] going on at least from
at least from what i've experienced
because i'm kind of like
even and i know tom is like maybe like a
different uh
case because he's had a head injury and
whatnot but even like
dudes that i've dated and i was married
for like 15 years
they forget everything they can't
remember
the simplest [ __ ] [ __ ] they can't
remember what day the garbage goes out
they can't remember like just regular
everyday normal
life [ __ ] they can't remember anything
they can't remember these birthdays
their
names or anything and they don't have
i don't know they seem to like can't be
able to like remember
or think about more than one thing at
once and i don't know if that's the case
because i'm not a dude
so i've never like thought that way but
to me it seems like very limiting
i don't know is that what it is scott
says you have no idea
i don't know if you're talking to me but
i don't know that's just how it always
seems to be i'm just like
i don't know i don't know and i don't
know if i'd be able to
like i said it would be easier in a lot
of ways because you could just like blow
a bunch of [ __ ] off
because like oh i don't have to remember
anything i'm just gonna like sit here
and
play video games or whatever and not
think about
[ __ ] i gotta do unlike me who gets up
wakes up at like five in the morning
thinking like oh my god i have to do
this this this this and it's like i'm
making lists in my head constantly of
like should i have to do
i don't know i don't know if that's like
might should be just me
uh tila says jenny if you were a dude
what would you look like
like if i could pick anything or if i
had to pick like a dude that sort of
looked like me
because that's a hard question you had a
package at the front door having to do
it
oh wait did i what is that
uh interesting
oh that's my battery for my uh oh it's
for the laptop for my
mac all right i wondered where that was
i thought it was supposed to come
yesterday
my little mac got a new lithium-ion
battery
tila asked me if i was a dude what would
i look like
i'd actually i'd like to look like david
bowie but maybe that's true
no i'm just like if
okay i mean if i could pick okay if you
could pick
or or maybe like peter cushing
i think i'd like i'd make a good peter
cushing i think
[Laughter]
no anything yeah she said if you could
just choose anything
all right david bowie or peter cushing
that's who i picked
i was saying while you were gone i was
like is it true
that dude's thought processes are just
boobs boobs boobs
ham sandwich boobs boobs boobs um
yeah okay so i was correct on that yeah
no not really it's boobs ass
boobs ham sandwich
uh face uh that no you're making me
and that's it yeah
so it's just kind of like so yeah it's
actually
that's that none of that shit's really
accurate
most of the time guys are actually
thinking about machines
oh yeah i forgot about that yeah most
guys are boobs boobs
engines machines it really starts
machines
yeah machines machines machines that fly
machines that shoot things machines that
go fast
engines machines uh that's that's
that's usually the thought process and
then puberty happens and it's
boobs machines face machines boobs
it's just like that
that makes sense though because
biologically men with their bodies
cannot create children
we don't gestate them but we can create
machines
and machines make sense people don't
make no sense they're not logical
even other guys are really not that
logical when you hear two guys talking
and there are no other women around it's
an exchange of information
they're talking about the history of
machines machines how machines work
i've heard you and bob dog yeah it's
like me and bob sitting there talking
and then we're talking about the history
machines
two hours yeah and and and about cars
and motorcycles
which like that's cool that's what
they're into yeah men make friends by
exchanging information about machines
and things sometimes inanimate objects
or systems so guys are
see this is something that i've always
trade information and like i said i
don't know if this is true or not
because i do kind of feel like
dudes are just more object oriented
they're not
people-oriented no no yeah and
so it's like it almost seems like and
but i don't mean this
to be insulting but it does really kind
of feel like they care more about
inanimate objects than they do about
people i think so
i mean that's just my experience i don't
know if that's the case
it's not in a bad way it's just that uh
men are very much into things that were
built
and machines and systems that were made
that that's
that's because it's a creation
of the mind and the hands you know yeah
i get that i like that kind of [ __ ] too
that's what that's
what they're talking about i'm just
saying but it wouldn't feelings aren't
really involved in it that much
in in the process it's not intimate it's
superficial
yeah but there's a depth to it that men
can recognize
know i mean there's like a spirituality
behind these machines and what they do
and like i said a conversation between
guys when there's just guys around is
very different than a conversation
say between men and women and women and
women it's it's about
[ __ ] objects and machines
it's trading in trading valuable
information
or recognizing that you that you guys
have the same information and appreciate
the information the same way
that's another thing it's another way oh
you know that one i know that one too
and then you know you heard me and bob
yeah we'll talk about the same thing we
both know the subject
well i mean but it's not that crazy
because like if i meet somebody else
that's into
for example horror movies or mystery
sciences like that
um like i will talk to that person the
same way that you talk to bob about
motorcycles or cars
and fighter fighter planes right you
know so it's not
that weird it's not as simple as like oh
dudes just
like dudes talk about machines and girls
talk about emotions that's not true
if i meet somebody that's super into
horror movies that is all we will
[ __ ] talk i will talk to
a person about horror movies for a
[ __ ] six hours
you know what i mean same kind of [ __ ]
and i you know if i meet somebody like i
said that's in a mystery science theater
and they're like as dorky about it as i
am
and we'll talk about it for hours and
hours then i'm very happy to do that so
it's not so much like a gender thing i
don't think
yeah i think it's slightly gendered
though because guys will start going
into [ __ ] things that women won't
give a [ __ ] about like
whether or not how do you raise
compression levels i mean should you use
a dome piston
or is it better just to use the [ __ ]
supercharger just blow it blow it in
there and pressurize the
pressurize the combustion chamber you
know by using forced induction you know
what i mean there's all kinds of weird
[ __ ] because it's going to get very
technical with dudes
you know and they might pull out paper
and pencil start doing math
and it's [ __ ] stupid because you
don't have the [ __ ] car there
you don't have the engine there nobody's
[ __ ] asking you to race
you're drunk and you're sitting there
trying to figure out what you know
what be a better way to go what would be
the rules would be you know that kind of
stuff
and guys get off all into that during
this time
beautiful women have walked behind you
eight times and you did and you missed
the teddies
but you're still going like that you're
still talking like that well and the
thing about it
is that your girlfriend your girlfriend
is running out with some other dude
is standing there listening to you for
three hours right and they're like you
know what i'm just gonna go dance and
find somebody right yeah
she's out there with some other dudes
that are passing around i'll go dance
with some weird [ __ ] you never know what
could happen
it's the weakness of men i'll go dance
with toby yeah
something like that who's gay as [ __ ]
but he's a really good dancer
and he likes all the same songs as me
yeah any you know so i'll go dance with
him because you're
like talking about motorcycles that's
that's just how we do
red mage 848 says now to see this is
really this is interesting information
it's simple yet complicated to be a dude
there's subtle intricacies to have to
walk to slack off and not being seen as
a fool instead of being seen as a
respectable man
as a guy you were expected to pick up
pick up slack and be a workhorse
but you try and ease that burden here
and there and you don't want to be seen
as a loser it's a balance
yeah i kind of yeah i see that i see
that
i kind of feel like i don't know being a
girl
i don't know i don't have anything to
compare it to being a girl is kind of a
[ __ ] too
because you are kind of expected to be
i don't know like pleasant and nice to
everybody and [ __ ] like that but then at
the same time you don't want to be
and then but if you're not nice to
people
then a whole like [ __ ] [ __ ] storm
erupts about
it i don't know it's just like
and then there's a whole thing about
other women because we're really like
psychological warfare kind of [ __ ] going
on
and there's like that whole thing oh
i don't know i i i feel like it's more
complicated to be a girl but i don't
know
maybe it's yeah it's more complicated
complicated being a girl
another thing is is that men and it's
been proven over and over again
men can be single and can die single
and be relatively satisfied it happens a
lot
and i don't think their mental health
suffers that much the average woman i
think it does
no actually from every psychological
study i've seen it's exactly the
opposite
i don't know it depends on who wrote
this um no like it's multiple ones over
the years
i've seen different women are generally
me women are generally happier
when they're single yeah uh men are
generally happier when they're in a
relationship what if they don't have
children
if they're single they don't have
children it's not factored into it they
were just talking about
single versus in a relationship like
married or
old women that have children are not the
same as an old woman that's single
i just say you know because they're not
really alone they have children
so they don't think they have the
feeling of being alone i don't mind
being but there meant a lot of guys
you're not alone no i'm just saying that
it you know
like when i went on vacation that wasn't
long though no but i'm just saying that
i don't mind actually
being alone i don't mind that yeah a lot
of guys are like that
their whole lives i don't i don't think
they really suffer that much from it
well science would beg to differ i think
science is corrupted it all depends on
who writes that science
how much you well no i'm just saying
that over the decades i've seen several
studies saying the same thing
uh men are generally happier and
healthier when they're in a relationship
women are usually happier and healthier
when they're single
i think those studies can say anything
you pay them to say
yeah yeah but you can say that about
anything well yeah i can and i do
i think most of the system is corrupt
because
i've seen all kinds of [ __ ] studies
on [ __ ] that [ __ ] wasn't true that i
knew about
you know what i mean like like
stopping power stopping power out of
[ __ ] pistol
bullets and rifle rounds and [ __ ] i
always knew that those second
that there was a a [ __ ] even
big they were scientifically trying to
prove in these law enforcement scenarios
that [ __ ] hollow points were the way
to go
that hollow points increased stopping
power and i was always [ __ ]
cynical of that because
it does it's technical i think there's a
very
little very little difference between a
full metal jacket and a hollow point
bullet because
any any hit that kills a man
with a [ __ ] hollow point bullet also
kills him if it was full metal jacket
the difference between the two is very
very slender and the full metal jacket
has armor penetration
there's a bunch of different things and
it was the big businesses involved in
the ammo [ __ ] company trying to sell
hollow points to the cops
and they were saying we didn't want to
over penetrate but no one had ever been
killed by a bullet that penetrated
through one person and hit another
you know some people have been hurt but
not killed so it's just it's hype
thank you gadget iii what do you say he
says cause why not goes why not
um yeah tila said
it's hard to be a girl it is but i
prefer it
we're more in touch with the universe
yeah that's what i'm saying i
i definitely think objectively i think
it is harder
but would i switch no would i want to be
a man
no no and
i don't know i i just there's something
about it i just i don't want to do that
i don't want to do that um
somebody said where was it where was it
where was it
yeah tila said only child here we enjoy
being alone it's important to be
comfy with that i actually have three
siblings
uh all younger and i grew up in an
environment
that my parents owned a daycare center
uh first like an actual daycare center
and then my mom ran a daycare center in
our house
so when i was a tween teenager
i always had [ __ ] children around
always and plus i have like a zillion
million
cousins who were all most of them are
younger than me
so i grew up around a lot of kids so
i grew up a lot of kids around a lot of
kids so
when i was a teenager i said i am never
having children because
[ __ ] this [ __ ] because i grew up around
it and i did not like it
uh and i have never regretted that
decision from that day to this
i think i told my mom when i was 16 i'm
never having children she said you'll
change your mind
i'm 48 i've been through menopause yeah
it that never happened i never regretted
it
but the thing about it is that i don't
know it just there's a thing
where the thing is though is that you
could have children
there are ways to turn the [ __ ]
reproduction i could but i don't
know if i would want to do you know that
you know that little tablet that they
give me for my hrt
that will bring a woman back into
that'll get a woman's [ __ ] metro
cycle going back
back up before like i thought about it a
couple times like i don't want to get
i don't know i don't know if we want to
get like that [ __ ] personal on this
[ __ ]
but it's like you can turn that right
back on
it's just why would you want to you know
i mean if i can
there are other things that that are
better than that
you know what i mean but i i don't know
i just kind of feel like
ever since i was a teenager and i'm not
[ __ ] on people that want to have
children there's nothing wrong with that
my mom loved kids
she had four of them she babysat them
she loves [ __ ] children
my brother is married uh his uh
wife had a couple of daughters
by a previous marriage and then they had
two sons
so they have four kids and uh they
[ __ ]
love it so if you're into it then that's
cool but it's just like
when i was a teenager i was like yeah i
don't ever i don't want to go
down this road and
i don't know i kind of left it open it's
like oh maybe i'll change my mind when i
get older but i just never did
i never did it just i don't know i don't
think it was
because i thought i would be a shitty
mom i don't think that i'd be a shitty
mom i think i've been awesome mom
it's just that i don't know there was
something about there was something
about that lifestyle i just i don't know
i didn't jive with it man it gets to a
certain point once you start getting
into your 30s if you don't have a kid
by that time you probably shouldn't have
one because that's really your prime
time
really to have one if you don't feel
like having it then then you probably
shouldn't
that's because you don't have enough
like as old as we are you don't have
enough time left to really
raise them that's what i mean it's like
i don't want
you could die you know what i mean in a
couple years and the kids still be
that's what i kind of think about it
it's like i kind of think about that and
it's weird because i thought about it
more since we
i know this is weird but i thought about
morrison's got pookie
because she you know she's not a human
child
i don't live very long ago but she's
kind of like
right she we kind of treat her as though
she's a human child
so i kind of feel like i kind of now i
kind of feel like
we think about her in terms of
you know who's going to take care of her
like if we die before she dies or
something like that you know what i mean
is she's
she's a cat but so i can see how that
would be like really [ __ ] difficult
yeah i don't know it's like i'm just
really really glad
i don't know every day i'm really glad i
didn't have a kid with my ex-husband and
i'm really really glad because that
would have been like a whole different
complication that i don't [ __ ] need
you know what i'm saying yeah if you had
a kid with your ex-husband then probably
we probably would never really have
hooked up anyway
that's what i mean because it would have
been like a whole yeah i wasn't
i [ __ ] you wouldn't have been out at
the clubs all the time i [ __ ] you
would have been taking kids taking care
of your kids i would have
never met you probably i'm just i don't
know man like i'm not a kid person
yeah and i don't like kids yeah
generally i don't have any children my
own so i tended to just kind of
naturally kind of avoid
single mothers you know what i mean and
i get that i couldn't really take care
of their kids you know
[ __ ] like i don't hate they're doing
their own thing
i don't hate children and i don't hate
people that have children if you want
children like good on you
but i don't know like i never
i never got the appeal of it there was
always single
women available that didn't have kids so
they were just a better choice and they
were the ones that were really trying to
date
so they kind of you know what i mean the
single moms really weren't trying that
hard
well because they think about who would
it be
they had other priorities yeah they had
other priorities angel which like i said
well telling you a little bit but sonia
wasn't really typical
yeah i mean she had a kid but yeah she
didn't go out still
yeah most of them didn't so that was
different
tila said people are getting better at
it but there was a lot of shaming of
women who didn't have kids yeah i
remember that it's not so bad now
but they did like people did kind of
look a scans at you if you said and
especially when i was growing up but i
was like a teenager i was like look i
don't
i'm pretty sure i like don't want any
kids because like i said i grew up
around a lot of children
yeah and i was pretty sure that i didn't
want that in my life
like from a pretty early age i'm gonna i
could take this [ __ ] back to history you
can go back to the old roman writings
not having kids is was actually a kind
of a [ __ ]
a metropolitan middle class thing that
started to happen even in ancient rome
the authorities of the time were like
worried because some of their best
people
most of their best people in their
middle class in their professional class
weren't having kids
because it cut into their incomes and it
cut into all their [ __ ] party time
because they were having a good time
well yeah it really does kind of like it
you know having kids it cramps your
style right
it really does yes because and then and
then all of a sudden your career goes
away especially if you're in an
entertainment-based industry in a
military-based industry
having being married and having kids you
shouldn't be in the military i mean you
had a lot of guys that were but you they
really shouldn't have been in there
all right especially in combat arms
why would you want to be away from your
wife all the time why do you want to be
cause you're never around
you should be a single man you know
adventure [ __ ]
i never really understood that um
but uh what ended up happening you know
is that [ __ ]
the rome the roman middle class started
to wane because he just didn't reproduce
and socially what ended up happening in
rome is that having kids was a poor
people thing
that's the way they looked at it yeah or
a very rich people thing
but rich men had several wives in their
career and a bunch of female sex slaves
well they didn't have to take care of
they didn't have to take care of it so
why would they care
but i would say the closest to a modern
person in the ancient roman system would
have been their professional class
and if you read about how they lived and
the way they thought
you can really see yourself in them
you know um and their thinking was a lot
like the average american
now was this a good thing no it wasn't
that [ __ ] that contributed to the
[ __ ] decline of the roman empire
but the roman empire had to decline it
was
it's all part of a cycle that couldn't
continue
and it was a it was in a way of [ __ ]
a civilization of injustice anyway
and lots and lots of corruption
was was the dark ages even better no but
that was the prog
that was the that was the
that was the process you had to go
through to eventually
start getting into the modern era you
know it takes
centuries just because it took a long
time that doesn't mean anything man our
lives are short
and we're just a small piece of this
[ __ ] picture being made you know
um big changes are happening now
all right i mean the population was
built upon
[ __ ] the industrial revolution and
the baby boom
the industry's kind of over they don't
want to make money that way anymore and
i understand why there's some downsides
to it mass production in the end
starts destroying companies because if
you make a [ __ ] ton of motorcycles the
value of them declines
so you had to make a new one and then
the value of that declines it's almost
like they're
putting out a lot of energy and a lot of
effort not
not just to stay afloat mass production
was kind of a
that the industrial revolution was all
about it was in a way
ultimately by the time the 70s and the
80s rolled around
kind of a waste of time it was kind of
detrimental to business
it's better to make small amounts of
high highly crafted items that'll last a
long time you know what i mean
investment is a lot better and i was
going to say that it's
better nowadays because there's not this
stigma about people that don't want to
have kids
so now people that have kids are people
that actually want them
and will raise them correctly instead of
just people having them because they
feel like they have to
and they didn't really want to have them
it's like this whole thing
so i kind of feel like now maybe there's
less
but they're more valued yeah well mass
production and
and endless growth and endless
reproduction of human beings
is not really the [ __ ] what's going
to happen what's going to happen is
you're going to have declining
populations but
increase in quality uh you don't need
large populations to run
around an economy it's going to be
[ __ ] devastating to a lot of people
but this is the way evolution is going
to happen a lot of it has to do with the
money
well like i said i think that's better
for everybody
across the board because like i said
everybody that's born
that's somebody that was wanted yeah
that's like people that actually wanted
a lot of they're gonna like raise you
correctly and then you have to look at
it this way though a lot of people will
not have children
so your genome is not passed to the to
the next right but it's like what's
up but that doesn't matter to anybody
really well
it matters to the people that are trying
to pass on their genes but you have to
look at it this way
let's say you have a child okay
that child is 50 percent related to you
the other 50
is related to the mother a couple
generations later
the offspring of that child a couple
generations later
is not really related to you that much
might be
or at least related to you in the same
experience everyone else
right right right all of a sudden now a
couple generations later
those children are only carrying maybe
10 percent of your genome
and that 10 percent that they're
carrying is very similar to the genome
that other people are [ __ ]
in other words random white people okay
yeah
generations on it's like it wouldn't
have mattered right that you didn't
because
you [ __ ] are all the same
once you [ __ ] start genetically i
mean they're humans yes we're very
widespread and [ __ ] like that
but genetically we're not really that
different so you start thinking
about it me i had a lot of ancestors
behind me if you go through the paternal
line
father and father and father and father
that's great but you gotta factor in the
moms too
and then all the [ __ ] other extended
family my great great great great
grandfather [ __ ] looks at me and goes
i ain't related to that [ __ ]
he'd be less related to me than say a
cousin wouldn't even be
a random aspect even a random person
right
not even a distant cousin so you kind of
come from nothing and you go back to
nothing [ __ ] i
met a random ass girl at summer cran
summer camp and she had the same great
grandfather as me
yeah and it's just a random person yeah
it was just a random person yeah
if you actually looked at the genomes
and the genetic similarities the genetic
similarities are the same as just a
random person
so a lot of what we were kind of raised
the way we're kind of instinctively
thinking
because we're programmed to think that
way not real accurate
your children belong to you your
grandchildren belong to you your great
great great great great chance gr
great great great grandchildren don't
have anything to do with you so you're
temporary anyway
and when you think about it the only
thing the only truths that are really
true
are truths that are always true and true
forever
which means almost everything is
temporary and almost
everything is just a temporary state of
being
well sure you know that's 99 of the
universe is just [ __ ] a temporary
state of being
i've made my peace with that reaction
jack [ __ ] to do with you
yeah and i'm totally i'm okay with that
and 200 years from now your name will
not even be remembered
and i'm okay with that and [ __ ] 20
years after your death you'll be
forgotten
unless you're a family unless you're a
famous person
i mean i've watched friends die five
years later there's nothing left of them
other than memories and then the people
that remember them eventually die
all their possessions are gone
everything they owned is gone it's just
it's not there anymore which is sad but
in a way of the force
well that's more an argument for
enjoying your life while you're here
because you can't guarantee that you're
gonna be remembered after you die
so while you're here do all the [ __ ] you
wanna do
when you're here because maybe no one
remember that [ __ ] 20
30 [ __ ] 50 years after you die nobody
will remember that maybe
yeah so just do what you want to do no
need for me says
entropy always wins out yes it does yeah
tila's going
um like i said i've i've come you know
tina's gonna make peace with that tina's
asking if anybody's done their ancestry
she wants to do the ancestor.com she's
want to know about her roots
that's what's gonna happen this is
what's gonna happen uh
t you're going to find out that um
you're black and you're white that's
what it's going to say
i did my um i was going to say i didn't
do ancestry.com i did
uh the national geographic thing because
they were doing like their
[ __ ] study or whatever i can only do
matrilineal
um so our [ __ ] i don't know if like
national geographic they had that whole
thing where they did the different uh
half-life groups
that were like with different letters i
was you
haplogroup which came uh out of africa
like everyone did and they and went
through the middle east
uh my people are from what is now turkey
that at least my my maternal line
because that's all they could do i
didn't like i wanted my brothers to do
some of the [ __ ] so i could get like the
paternal but i don't know
yeah but i did that yeah t
if you um if you uh go on youtube
and just look at people's ancestry
results
it it's funny you know
it's and [ __ ] one of the things is i
watch one or they had some
black chick she got her ancestry results
back
and she was [ __ ] surprised to find
out that she was like 40
[ __ ] european and i was like well of
course
you know what i mean most black people
in the united states are
forty to fifty percent european well and
most white people in the united states
are probably forty to fifty percent
black
no that would be the same as a forty
five no
[ __ ] if you it because that would
make you the same as
as a black person that was 40 european
it'd be the same
if most white people are probably more
like
well you could probably you can look on
there and look i mean you still have
some of them
that [ __ ] don't don't have any
african ancestry
i have some middle eastern in me yeah i
do as well
which you know syrian and that's because
my grandfather his mother was a syrian
christian
um which evidently was pretty common uh
back in the back in the olden days there
were a lot of syrians
coming in into the united states
i don't really know what the deal is but
evidently that had something to do with
even going back to the 1700s
they said that thomas jefferson was part
syrian
yeah i don't know what was happening
well that's something that had something
to do with religion that's the thing i
just
kind of feel like everything is really
everybody wants to be like this pure one
thing or another but nobody really
is nobody is well
europeans are europeans they're all
about the same
uh there are some scandinavians the only
thing that was second distinct from what
i remember was laplanders
evidently like lapland the laplandish
people or almost their own race
that's the last i heard but uh
no i mean african americans have been in
the united states for a long time you
know there's a lot of cross
in what they call admixture which is
cross breeding lots of it
and you don't really think about it much
if you look at your average black person
they just look african
but if you put them next to an african
person they look
they don't look that african anymore
i mean it depends on who you're talking
about yeah because they've been here for
generally yeah they've been here for
generations
and the same thing happened with me it's
just kind of like like i said my
matrilineal line
came through the middle east yeah uh
mainly turk what is now turkey
and then went to europe and then came
here my dad's side of the family
irish but also blackfoot indian
and so you get all that going on too and
it's just kind of like i kind of feel
like everybody is
super mixed at this point at least in
this country
you have to see the test so yeah it's a
mix it's a mix but it was always was
you know what i mean like even you look
into europe
in the european history the southern
europeans that kind of have that
mediterranean look to them
that could have been a bunch of
different things one of the things that
happened is that there was the moorish
conquest
of europe which there was kind of like
the moors had occupied europe for a
while
which had kind of and they had bred in
the moors were from
middle east and northern africa and that
kind of
they darkened a little bit they're still
europeans though
you know you end up with like you know
the italians or something you know
sicily you know people from sicily
but then you could say well you know if
you look at uh ancient
roman statues and the way they described
themselves they were kind of
mediterranean looking to begin with
anyway so it might have been that same
replay
over and over again where you had people
kind of coming from north africa in the
middle east
into southern europe over and over again
in successive waves
in the same way that a lot of america
was influenced by the damn
irish diaspora that went everywhere you
know
oh yeah big time which you know that's
even down into
people don't realize it but [ __ ]
south america has a lot of irish blood
in it
um you know you'll see
mix you know like mchenry and
you know make this and make that in
brazil
you wouldn't think so but it is
camp guy says i had two first cousins
the hemophilia
let me tell you about that my
grandfather
had hemophilia um
i don't know if it killed him
necessarily because he had
a brain hemorrhage and that's what
killed him my mom
actually found him in his apartment but
he passed the hemophilia gene on
to all of his children who all have it
to a greater lesser degree he had eight
children
which are all my aunts and uncles and my
mom yeah
now some of them had it worse than
others the weird thing about
this is that hemophilia i don't know if
you guys know but a particular kind of
hemophilia
it usually manifests in males
but it's like women are carriers
however that's not what happened in my
family
in my family i had several aunts
who were you know my sisters uh my my
mom's sisters
who manifested hemophilia just like a
man would
and they were actually studied back in
the 60s and 70s
like because of this because it was very
unusual
now later on some of them um
had children against the advice
of their doctors because they said look
if you try to like give birth you'll
might bleed to death uh so don't
so um a lot of them when they had
children it was like a big huge problem
and [ __ ] like that
um uh so you know they had to have
transfusions and whatnot
now interestingly it passed on to the
third generation as well
because i know of at least one
of my cousins a female who had
a little boy who also has full-on
hemophilia
so i don't know my mom kept like bugging
me she's like look if you're gonna have
any kids you really need to like
test for that [ __ ] because you might
bleed to death like when you have
uh children so you really need to check
because there's
i didn't know this but there's like a
there's different types of hemophilia
there's basically a look cut man i'll
like bleed to death or there's like
minor
more minor ones because some of my ants
had
had it but like not to an extent where
they would bleed to death at like the
littlest thing but it was just kind of
like something that had to be like
looked into
yeah so what i was gonna say t said that
my cousin had her ancestry done and she
was
and their cousin was seven percent
swedish she was like really
and she goes she's proud to be muddish
nothing you can do
okay ancestors were chopping off girls
clits okay yeah she's talking about
clitorectomy and stuff
yeah yeah um yeah if your cousin was
seven percent swedish then you you could
go get yours done man you're gonna be
surprised you're gonna find all kinds of
weird [ __ ] in there
yeah yeah camp guys said women with
hemophilia can bleed to death from their
periods
well yeah like i said and hemophilia
runs in my family so it was something
that i worried about
but i mean because when i was growing up
i didn't have any
surgeries i didn't really have anything
that would have caused me to question it
so when i got older my mom was like you
really need to get checked because
you know if you plan on having any
children or if you get an accident or
something like that you might like
[ __ ] bleed to death without anybody
knowing
and so i never did though but there's
different like stages of it
like i said my mom kind of has it my
aunt kind of has it
but the thing about it is that it kind
of skips generations
so my female cousin had a
little boy and he has full-on hemophilia
she has it kind of but
his is kind of like the one where you
have to like watch all the time like you
can't like [ __ ]
scratch anything but i don't know it's
like it's [ __ ] up but that came from
my grandfather as far as i know and i'm
sure it
probably came from farther back than
that yeah t
says yeah my cousin inspired me to get
hers done i'm going on ancestor dna next
week i'll let you know the results yeah
we'd like to see the results
yeah i'm interested it's like i just
i i did it because i was reading a book
about
you did yours done you did you had yours
i just
i said that yeah all right i was through
no but it actually gave you like racial
profiles and where everything came
from all right all right on my
matrilineal side okay
i just on the other side i said that you
guys no i'm i'm reading the damn
comments
i'm reading sections i can't i can't
monitor what you're saying all the time
yeah i had that done like years ago
i had done like years ago yeah well they
can only do my
um mitochondrial dna right which is my
that's my matrilineal side
um if i wanted the male dna done my
brothers would have to do it
right you know what i mean and i think i
got it done through
national geographic because they were
doing a study and i saw a documentary
about it and i wrote a
i read a book about it and i was like
really interested in there so is it
european and native american and uh
middle eastern middle eastern yeah okay
mostly middle eastern yeah um on my on
my
mother's side yeah it's weird how that
happens because i have that too
yeah but there was some kind of turkey
it was mostly yeah
turkey syria around that area it must
have something to do
with the eastern roman empire
or you know it has it has to go back
that far i would think
so i have the same genotype as do you
guys remember
like several years back when they found
that
was it a mummy or was it like a i
remember they found like
a mummified person
from like that era and they did a
reconstruction
what was he called something man but he
was from right around turkey somewhere
and when he when they did like the
facial reconstruction
i was like yeah that's that's my nose
right there
and i have the same uh genotype as him
as that guy so tease asks if i get my
done yeah i should get mine done
you should yeah it's a well when i did
it that was like several years ago i
think it was like
a hundred dollars yeah oh it's probably
cheaper now and all you got to do you
got to swab the inside of your mouth and
send like the [ __ ]
they want the blood huh no they don't do
blood you just you just scrape
some cells off the inside of your cheek
okay and then you send it in a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] and like i said this was
years ago i did it but i
i'm in the same haploid group as whoever
that famous like mummy was
from [ __ ] turkey or whatever yeah
what the [ __ ] was he called something
something man i can't remember now but
they did a facial reconstruction i'm the
same half blue group as that guy
yeah yeah she's that telling me to get
down it's gonna it's gonna be
you should it be it's super interesting
it's gonna be european
middle eastern pry some native american
probably some african if the if if it
fits
along with the basic mississippi profile
that's probably
the african and indians could probably
be in this in the single digits
scott asked was it etsy the iceman no it
wasn't i can't remember who the [ __ ] was
that [ __ ]
i can see his face they had a name for
him but i can't remember what it was and
i can see it's like
the reconstruction they made but i can't
remember what they call them
it was somebody they found in that
region
but i'm the same haplogroup as that guy
uh yeah yeah you should actually get
that it's
it's like i said it's fascinating well
they can do it nowadays too because
you can either do it like for your kind
of just
genetic edification just to see like
where you came from which is interesting
or you can do one where they tell you
like what diseases you're likely to get
i don't know if i would do that or not i
don't want to know you can kind
you should you can kind of know what
it's going to be by
where your families are from and what
the makeup of those areas form when who
migrated into that area
and there was already middle eastern
influence
in the uk and in the british people and
the irish people
before they started leaving and making
colonies in the new world so that's
where a lot of that comes from
well yeah you know there was a middle
eastern act because the
all the whole turkey thing turkey and
syria and all these other places
well there were hot spots of [ __ ]
where good [ __ ] was happening with trade
and information so it was like part of
the economy at that time
and rich people could travel so a lot of
times rich people carried that stuff
yeah because they could they were rich
enough to travel and intermarry
or have foreign wives that type of deal
well yeah that's why i kind of feel like
yeah in this day and age probably race
is like a meaningless construct because
everybody's related to everybody
in some to some degree yeah well all
people are people
yeah they all have commons ancestry but
we also have common ancestors with
things that aren't human
or things that were like the neanderthal
so that's not really a big deal
everything's related to everything i
mean you stand a cat up on its back legs
you go boy that looks a lot like a
person well in a way it is it's
all those mammals have combinations well
honestly i kind of treat
cats like people yeah they're really not
that different
it's really not that different and i'm
not just being weird
so they're not that different not really
it's a process it's a process of
evolution all mammals
everything is a process our i mean if
you look at it from like the long view
are pretty closely related yeah if you
took a human a chimpanzee and a cat and
a bear threw them all together in the
same [ __ ]
cell and gave that to aliens they would
look at that and they would go those
animals all look related
yeah that's they would yeah that's what
they would say well and
you know if you've owned a pet yeah you
know to any degree
their facial expressions their reactions
to things
are very equivalent to human reactions
to things
yeah it's really not that they all
inherit that same thing pokemons these
faces and [ __ ] like what
and you know exactly what that face is
surprised faces or
faces like i don't approve
[Laughter]
yeah it's all that same thing yeah it's
like i don't have any problem at all
you know um interpreting her facial
expressions or her body language or
anything
because it's just pretty much like a
there are some differences but
not really that much it's the same with
those bears yeah
you look at the bear and the bear goes
oh [ __ ] and you recognize the oh [ __ ]
look
yeah then it runs away with tail between
his legs oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
reptiles not so much but you know well
that's a different thing yeah but
mammals they
generally not always like i said it's
not a one-to-one
but if it's a mammal then it's
pretty related to you and
it's pretty i mean their facial
expressions and body language
is probably pretty similar to yours
probably yeah
he was saying that a race is a social
construct
created to divide i kind of differ
races race is real but it's not that
important
it's uh it's like breed it's a
superficial
well there's there's other stuff to it
though too yeah but i mean
generally it's pretty superficial though
it's people in certain areas have
adapted to their environment
and when you adapt to a certain
environment you're going to look a
certain way
and uh you these people were bred each
race was kind of bred to survive in its
habitat by
forces in nature it's it's it's just a
part of humans the same thing that
happens to huma
to animals and if if race goes on
long enough in isolation it starts to
become a new species
that's why big cats there's lions tigers
and cheetahs they're all big cats
but they went beyond race or breed
they're now
different species but that takes a long
time for that process to happen
thank you david man donating in tila's
name because she rules
[Laughter]
like there's this there's this guy man i
got tila i got to give you a [ __ ]
the link off when i find it [ __ ] it's in
here i just
started subscribing to this guy he's
this skinny old [ __ ]
kind of soy ass kind of white boy with
this [ __ ] beard and [ __ ] he goes down
to all these other countries who's in
mexico
and he's he he's traveling that's his
job is to travel around with his
and stream it he goes to um to mexico
and he just he was in uh he was on the
african continent for several months he
went to
i think it was zambia was one of them or
and uh the other one
i remember he went to a couple of them
and he has all kinds of fun in africa
and he does some just some funny [ __ ]
but one of the things that he was doing
is he had this girl who was
guiding around these african villages
and this little girl who was probably
about
four or five [ __ ] loses it
this girl [ __ ] starts screaming her
head off
because she had never seen a white dude
before and it's just
he's gonna eat me and [ __ ] this and
that and all you know they had to
[ __ ] check they had to chase her down
and [ __ ] hold her still and she's
waiting the white man's gonna eat me and
[ __ ] um maybe
he might yeah he might
the adults are trying to keep her calm
no it's okay it's just a white man you
know
and he has to come up there and be able
to hold her hand for a while
he could speak he can speak a couple
different african languages and he's
talking to her and and
i don't remember the name of that
language it was you can see it he
finally [ __ ]
you know calms her ass down so there you
know
there are there are differences it is
not it is not created to divide us
nature did it because of where we lived
over time
well i and a little difference yeah
it's not a racial difference no well no
you you evolve
to to look differently to fit that
environment
you do right but evolution doesn't work
as fast as
it takes millions of so hundreds years
yeah
i mean you could take a person that was
born there right
and you could bring them like before
they were all that old is what i'm
saying you could bring them to
say the uk and you could raise them
there and they would totally assimilate
yeah today you could right not back in
the day well no but i'm just talking
about it
today you could because a lot of it has
to do with modern diet and
having access to clothing and shelter
you know what i mean
a lot of these a lot of these [ __ ]
changes happened to people that created
races
was before the advent of [ __ ]
clothing that's how far back it goes
before the advent of [ __ ] shipping
and being able to get to get certain
foods everywhere you know vitamin d had
a lot to do with it
all right but no the little girl [ __ ]
reacted normally she saw a person
that was different than everybody else
and she [ __ ] lost it
but the adults and everything knew that
there were other people this is a
village that doesn't even have
television
you know yeah so that's the kind of
reaction you would have
in ancient times when you're
surviving subsistence types farmers or
hunter-gatherers
and you see another type of human that
you've never seen before
that's going to eat me that's probably
that's going to be the primal [ __ ]
reaction that's why you find all those
damn
cooked pre-human bones that have been
stripped of flesh and [ __ ]
because they did eat each other you
didn't kind of look like me but not
yeah you're not not enough like me i'm
not [ __ ] eating
yeah this is not this is not the world
that we want to have
this is the world that we were given all
right and it was the animal kingdom
okay but but you gotta like
persevere and like get above that white
people
are white because they evolved in an
area where there wasn't enough sunlight
to get [ __ ] we're trying to soak in
all the vitamin d vitamin d
right because of our pale ass and you
have places we weren't getting enough
vitamins places around the equator and
in africa
uh yeah you had no problem with vitamin
d
uh you didn't need heavy clothing there
wasn't a [ __ ] strong winter
so all that had the white features are
all about
surviving in cold environments where
there isn't much light
and that's why we look the way that we
do and that's the only reason
yeah well it was selectively bred but
you can selectively breed a
breed a person into looking like
anything especially with genetic
engineering that's coming
i predict that after genetic engineering
is perfected
people will look like that
damn anime vr porn characters that's
probably what they'll look like well
honestly they'll look like
there's no way to predict because people
could just like predict to whatever
i could predict they could look like
whatever they wanted to look like i can
predict what it'll look like it will be
all of the traits people fantasize about
on the same person
and that would be like something out of
anime
very thin big boobs big eyes
little diamond shaped head elongated
real strong it they'll look like
something like that
they'll be they'll look like a barbie
doll because if you
look at the way a modern person looks
today and you compare that to a
primitive like homo erectus we are far
more sexy looking than they are they're
short little squat bodies they weren't
good looking
and it's because we selectively bred
ourselves to look like this we
chose good looking features and compared
to all ancient people's world everybody
was goddamn planets better looking than
them
because good looking features went out
in the [ __ ] sexual arms race
that's why chimpanzees look the way that
they do they don't have [ __ ] wide
hips and big boobs and [ __ ] you know
pretty faces and [ __ ] well they don't
that wasn't their hips because
that wasn't the reason we have wide hips
is because our baby's heads are so big
the reason why we have well it's it's
okay
i read all this [ __ ] too jenny it's a
lot more to it than that
you have intelligent creatures that are
intelligent enough to understand
gestalt and the difference between ugly
and beautiful
that slowly starts to create better
looking
more intelligent more beautiful things
it's kind of like it's a chicken or the
egg type of deal
yeah the hips had to be wider because it
had a bigger head and a bigger brain
but it had a bigger brain and it could
grasp the idea of beauty
and it's and it one thing kind of
fed into the other but what made a human
a human is that it had pride in what it
did
it didn't just make tools it decorated
tools it didn't just throw
rocks it tried to throw rocks better
than the competition
and chimps even though they're
intelligent and gorillas they're pretty
intelligent
they don't do that they don't compete
with one another
they don't put on jewelry you know what
i mean
they don't only because they haven't
figured it out yet they're not
intelligent enough
right they don't have that kind of
appreciation left yet
but you know if you were to [ __ ]
expand
through genetic engineering but they get
the concept of that though
i kind of feel like they get the concept
the general concept
not according to what i've read
it's like the difference between
a chimpanzee can do certain things it
has a real
strong men it has really good memory it
should have
a little bit more intelligent than than
a human child
but a human child can speak in a
chimpanzee can't and can grasp language
and a chimpanzee
can't really grasp it that well because
symbolism isn't quite there yet
and then you have humans that can create
[ __ ] classical music
and to something that would be more
intelligent than us that classical music
and all that high art would be like
something that a chimpanzee could do
so it's all kind of like we see
ourselves as something real
high-minded because that's all we have
to compare it to
but if we start talking to aliens which
would probably be some kind of a.i
alien could come down here and our best
minds would be like
their children could do that that's what
it's going to be like
well yeah and they're not even if i can
consider us as being really intelligent
because we're not no we would be like a
chimpanzee compared to them
yeah but one of the things that this and
you know i've seen with
anthropologists said i'm not pulling
this out of my ass the difference was
is that humans have a sense of pride
in craftsmanship and workmanship and
they compete against one another
for a lot of different so things in
social status and that drove
evolution forward without that it kind
of stagnates you just stay in the animal
kingdom
let's see everybody saying i gotta pee
okay stuck
yeah i'm gonna talk it's getting late we
probably ought to end the damn stream
how long we been doing
i don't know okay still daylight out
yeah that tells you anything it's not my
idea uh
dean i got that from anthropologists
that
talked about it
yeah victor oh she said that
mesoamericans got plenty of sun
they don't look like africans the thing
is though is that a lot of the major
racial traits didn't happen
in the modern era and the mesoamericans
all that [ __ ] was much later
we're talking about a long time even
like before humans
some of that stuff was even before some
of that genetic information that created
things like
eye color and hair color and texture
and skin color a lot of those genes
existed before homo sapien so it goes
that far back
um
yeah once they get that genetic
engineering of the the
the sexual arms race will be over
because then
you can just make any kind of human that
you want the problem is
is that uh the problem is about is that
humans won't be
humans will not be biologically making
these humans through sexual reproduction
it'll probably be corporations making
them in a [ __ ] artificial womb
and they pop out kind of like a
corporate employee you know
kind of like one of those damn
replicants
but uh which is why why y'all [ __ ]
gotta go i mean they can probably do
that now
i have i have a suspicion that that they
could probably raise
human fetuses genetically engineered
human fetus is probably in some kind of
like a maybe a goat or a sheep or maybe
a pig
they probably could do something like
that
so that wouldn't surprise me i wouldn't
surprise me if they keep a lot of this
information from us of what's actually
possible
so if they can genetically engineer
[ __ ] just badass human beings then
our days are numbers
they'd replace us all what would they
need us for
the thing about genetic engineering
though is that there is still
a you know there there's a large margin
of error
uh there's too much [ __ ] that could go
wrong there's too much [ __ ] that go
differently
i kind of feel like it's safer to just
make everything
mechanized so i don't know if
genetic engineering is going to go that
way necessarily because like i said
genetics is just like
that's what's really scott said it's too
complicated yeah
if you want to do something simple you
just want people that's gonna like work
for you or whatever just like build
[ __ ] replicants
that don't have any uh genetic material
because they can't go awry
yeah no no no genetic
replicants did have genetic information
well i'm just saying that
you just build like [ __ ] ai or robots
or something like that
because it you know if you have anything
with an organic or genetic component
component there's gonna be some aspect
of
wild card in there that you're not gonna
be able to control
and that's i kind of feel like that's
always going to happen yeah
so because you don't you can't control
that
so either build a robot
or i don't know so that's why i'm not
like all that worried about genetic
engineering because i feel like that's
ultimately going to be a dead end
yeah but it's not going to be
controllable that's just like you said
though that's the way
that's what you're feeling it that's
mostly feelings who knows what they have
i don't know what they have they well i
know you like to like
tell me i'm wrong about everything but
it's like you know what i mean
no i'm just trying to we don't really
know what the state of the art is
because they probably wouldn't tell us
well i can imagine what the state of the
art is i'm just saying if it was me
and i knew anything well and i knew what
i know about
genetic uh science um
i'm just saying that's not the route
that i would go there are too many
variables that are
outside of your control that's all i'm
saying and and are always going to be
like that
so i kind of feel like that's really not
the direction you want to go
if you want like complete control over
something or something that's going to
work the way you think that it's going
to work
all the time you try to do [ __ ] with
genetic engineering that's not
it's not going to go the way you think
it's going to go it never does
that's just how that [ __ ] works so i'm
just saying if it was me
i wouldn't go that route yeah i'm just
saying all right tea
the name of that channel is called
sabbatical
and this is trying to see where the
little kid little kid starts screaming
and crying
there she is they're trying to show him
the white man white people trying to
show him the white man yeah she's crying
over that white man
they took him over there to show her the
white man she because she went
she saw him from a distance and just
[ __ ] took off [ __ ] running
pokey yeah this cookie's arrived you
guys
do look that he goes he's going to eat
me he's not going to eat you
oh he's not there he might eat
okay come on polk she tried to jump here
jump up here earlier and like everything
slid off and she
got really upset he's trying to set up
trying to settle her down she's eating
your wig
she's gonna be don't eat the wig try to
settle her down
yeah she's like i i don't like the
situation
it's an interesting channel it's called
sabbatical come here
and then like he almost gets forced into
um
he scared her he almost gets forced into
um
polygamy into polygamy
he goes into a bar and
the woman that owns the bar um
said go over there and talk to my
daughters and
the dog this is their messiah and
they're both trying he
they're telling him that he's got two
wives now so they're [ __ ] with him he
started [ __ ]
he's messing with he buys everybody's
drinks and [ __ ]
he's like [ __ ] funny that's cool yeah
yeah they're teasing him and [ __ ] it's a
good one sabbatical
that's a good channel
yeah i i just kind of feel like if it
was me if i was some big like super
villain corporation like spectre or
whatever
um and i was trying to like make a bunch
of
drones that didn't question me and blah
blah i would totally not go the genetic
route because it seems like a lot of
investment into science that's not gonna
go the way you think it's gonna go
because there's too many variables that
you can't control too many variables you
can't control
you might as well just like build some
[ __ ] ai and even in that direction
even ai has some emergent properties
that you can't entirely control but if
those are your two options
i would go completely
you know digital ai kind of [ __ ] over
genetic engineering because
genetic engineering you're just going to
get too many [ __ ] emergent properties
and you
you're not going to be able to control
like the outcomes
the way that you think you're going to
be able to so how long have we been
streaming
jenny three hours and 36 minutes okay
i think it's about time we shut this
[ __ ] down man you think so oh man i've
been streaming too long i've been
working for three hours
dean asked me if i liked the old basil
rathbone sherlock holmes movies i do
indeed
actually i really liked a basil wrath
phone we should do one of those
we should review one of those i guess
scott says we can't even make the
internet work properly yeah
that's what i'm saying it's like that's
one
that's why i'm not like super into like
all these conspiracy theories oh
somebody's like running all the [ __ ]
it's like dude we can't even
i can't even get [ __ ] facebook to
work right so come on
come on nobody is like smart enough to
figure that out there are too many
things
there are too many people involved
there's too much technology involved
that
most people don't understand there are
too many things that like you do this
thing and it does these other things
that you didn't expect
too many emergent properties all right
see you no need for me see around bro
yeah you can't control it yeah um so
i don't that's why i don't worry about
it because it's just too [ __ ]
ramshackle and it's too
random and
i just don't think like nobody is smart
enough to like control that [ __ ] no one
person
nobody sorry there's just too much [ __ ]
going on
every time i watch blade runner says
grant there's hammer
i see actual predictions of the future
like when deckard zoom calls rachel
[Laughter]
i kind of feel like that it's weird
because a lot of uh i feel like a lot of
media didn't see internet coming but
blade runner kind of did and as much of
it as [ __ ] as he was
orson scott card kind of saw that [ __ ]
coming too because in the [ __ ]
uh that book that he wrote [ __ ] man what
was the one that made that a movie
but he had um a real early and i think
he wrote in the 60s
but there was something in it that was
pretty much like the internet
and i kind of feel like he was one of
the only people that
maybe predicted that i didn't read a lot
of sci-fi from that era
but i kind of feel like that was
something a lot of people didn't see
coming
but he kind of saw it coming it wasn't
exactly the same
but he got the gist of it you know what
i'm saying where somebody would like
upload their
scientific papers and everybody in the
world could read it
you know yeah um you know so
so that was that whole thing out
colossus the forbidden project yeah we
have to uh
do that
where am i yeah in the 60s they were
doing art but yeah they were
that's true what's up volky what's the
matter pokey she's calling me she wants
something
she's growling yeah if you want
something to eat
you want something to eat okay i gotta
go
okay well fine look at her look at her
all right well i guess he's not gonna
help me finish this [ __ ]
i guess we're going um tomorrow
i'm gonna put up a movie review and then
friday night we'll be back on a live
stream we're gonna be talking about
a subject that i'm sure tom is very
excited about the north hollywood
shootout
bank robbery kind of thing happened back
in the 90s
big huge [ __ ] shootout in la la uh so
we're gonna be talking about that a
couple people requested it tom was like
excited about it so we're gonna do it on
friday night
uh so that'll be in our next live stream
we'll have some videos up tomorrow and
we'll have one up friday morning as well
we're doing a review of the relic from
1997.
so excuse me keep a eye out for that
and i guess we're gonna wrap it up for
tonight because he went to go feed the
cat
i guess she didn't want anything she
didn't want to she didn't want anything
she didn't want to go outside well
i'm trying to like wrap the [ __ ] up she
called me she said would you hurt her
but yeah she was growling yeah like okay
thank you david thank you so much
she's back in here so i guess we're
gonna go you ready to go
yeah well [ __ ] we've been streaming
three and a half hours yeah
yeah pookie's getting all like [ __ ]
restless
all alright so we will be we will see
you guys again live on friday evening
so have a good rest of your day your
evening
and we will see you guys on friday
[Music]
bye